the cuomos they're gone both of them wow
Andrew Cuomo's ousted in this pest
Scandal we'll keep a little family
friendly and now his brother has been
suspended from CNN indefinitely
I guess they say pending further review
so maybe they're gonna wait for
everything to die down and try and bring
him back or maybe this is it the
brothers Cuomo have been officially
canceled and they're both gone I mean
this is big because none of us thought
this was gonna happen we said yesterday
that maybe he'd get fired and everyone's
response was it will never happen Manuel
you know to be honest he still wasn't
fired but he's off the air so that'll be
really interesting we gotta talk about
that we also got to talk about what
Twitter is doing because Twitter is now
going to be censoring all media
from individuals if you don't have their
consent now they say if you're a public
figure maybe we'll allow it if it's
newsworthy we'll see depending on the
context but we're really worried that
you know private or or information can
be used against women and minorities and
activists and dissidents so we
understand where that is going and then
we got new information coming out of the
Kim Potter trial the Dante Wright
shooting there's a jury selection is
ongoing and of course Jesse Smollett so
we'll get into all of that stuff a lot
of really great stories today and
joining us to go through all of this is
Matt Walsh
yeah it's great great to be here you
know I'm uh I have a my own podcast the
Matt Walsh show but I I what I uh really
am now embracing is my my role as a
children's author
and uh I forgot my cardigan but Johnny
walrus is on sale right now it's uh was
on Amazon we sold out in one day Whoa We
charted number four
um my story about a trans walrus and um
we sold out but we're gonna restock it
go to Johnny the walrus.com and get the
get the book and I saw uh the reviews
are all you know pretty good people
being like hey this is this is a great
thing yeah I think all the reviews are
people that didn't actually read the
book yet but right but but still you
know they could just tell based on the
cover
I think we've got we got sent one and
I'm pretty sure I did read it yeah but
but I like the one star reviews are not
about the book they're about the
perceived politics of the book which I
find interesting because it's a
children's book so it's not explicit
it's implicit yeah so they're upset
about the implicit narrative
as it's also it's also funny because the
the book is about a little child who's
imaginative and creative and you know he
pretends to be different things and then
he pretends to be a wall race one day
and he's got like wood spoons in his
mouth as tusks and um and uh and his
then his mother Endeavors to actually
raise him as a walrus as like a you know
because she's she's been told by the
internet you have to raise a child
however they identify so I don't say
anything about Trans in the books or the
people that the critics that are saying
they're the ones kind of making that
connection so
Hey There It Is Well uh awesome man glad
to have you we'll talk some news and we
also got Luke hanging out we're gonna do
a reading later which I'm really excited
about uh hi my name is Luke my YouTube
channel is we are change and one of my
core principles is that if you need
violence to enforce your ideas then your
ideas are worthless and I was like Hey
that could make a really good t-shirt so
I decided to make one and if you want
one of your own you can get it
exclusively on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and because
you do I'm still here so thanks for
having me appreciate it that's a Veiled
Threat by the way he's like it is you
don't buy my shirts I'm leaving yeah
I'll be gone Florida seems really nice
right now that's how true it does that's
true I don't know if you've done the
audio version of that yet the uh Johnny
The Walrus the reading it would be like
a 30-second audiobook but ring the bell
to turn the page did you ever have those
growing up those records no I'm going
way back to the years
when you turn the page the belt ring no
no I don't remember the records yeah I
remember that that's pretty cool I
remember those little books where they
have the goal old you know yeah the gold
binding yeah binding yeah
unfamiliar unfamiliar territory thank
you true yes we're having flashbacks
over here great books I'm excited to
talk about this kid's book because I was
listening to Matt talk about it on the
way on my commute and I was like this is
actually a really good idea and I think
people are liable to dismiss it and
think it's silly but at the same time
just because the pages are cardboard
literature yeah seriously yeah but
you're like an advanced children's
author even though you're not wearing a
cardigan we're prepared to accept this
and I'm really excited to talk about it
it was it wasn't you who wrote the book
with no words in it was it Michael
Knowles that was no it's okay okay very
very prestigious authors you know well
he's kind of the same position I am
because you know he's he's written like
real books and he's got his blank book
and he'll he'll never sell as many
copies of any real book as he rolled a
blank book and I'm in the same I wrote
two real books and nobody read them and
then I then and then you know I write
this and it sells out in one day so
great you know it's it's I think it's
it's useful to parents who want that
message so it makes sense but uh all
right before we get started ladies and
gentlemen go to lightbug.com
l-y-t-e-b-u-g.com for probably the
simplest product we've ever had sponsor
the show and it's actually pretty cool
this is the light bug it is a solar
powered LED light with multiple settings
it's got this little solar panel here
and it can actually fold up at 180
degrees you can use it to prop it up so
if you need an emergency light or
emergency kit for your car or your cabin
or maybe you're going off-roading or
something and you want it this thing's
really cool because not only is it a
light it's also a USB phone charger so
it's kind of like a big bulky version of
what we shouted out yesterday which was
the solar charger it's a solar powered
battery this one it's actually a solar
powered light and it just so happens you
can charge your phone off it it really
is that simple so you know in the event
of an emergency I think these things
would be pretty great to have in your
vehicle and that's really all we have to
say I mean it's it's as I mentioned five
times now it's simple because so go to
l-y-t-e-bug.com shout out to these
companies that are willing to sponsor
shows like this because of course we
talk about we talk about things that the
mainstream The Establishment the
corporate press aren't too big aren't
big fans of so any any one of these
companies that wants to get behind you
know the work we do we're eternally
grateful for and again lightbug.com
you'll get 50 off and use the promo code
timcast25 for an additional 25 off but
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member and you can directly support all
of our journalists and you can get
access to our exclusive members only
segments of the show we put them up
every night around 11 or so p.m so
you're not going to want to miss it
they're fantastic and they're not family
friendly a lot of swearing a lot of
nasty stories but you know this is the
real the dark stuff that we like to get
into but don't forget also to smash the
like button subscribe to this Channel
and I'm also extremely excited to
announce
YouTube actually approved our step on
snack and find out shirt and now it is
pinned in the chat because we we put
that up over a month ago it's a month
and a half and YouTube was not approving
it and then all of a sudden it appeared
and now we're able to pin it so if you
haven't seen that yet actually I don't
think I have it pulled up but if you uh
you should check it out it's awesome
it's funny I love it let's get into that
news and uh yeah share the video and all
the stuff let's talk about Chris Cuomo
we got this story from the New York
Times CNN suspends Chris Cuomo after new
details on help he gave his brother the
cable news Network's top rated anchor
was an enthusiastic advisor to Andrew
Cuomo in the last 18 months of his
governorship but I love how they don't
use the headline Chris Cuomo suspended
indefinitely after stalking the victims
of his creepy Cuomo brother instead
they're like well he was helping his
brother it's almost like you're trying
to sound like make it sound like a good
thing and get people to be like how
could they do that to Chris Cuomo but
this is an example of media collusion
Democrat friendly media Chris Cuomo on
CNN CNN of course is not a news
institution at this point they're
content creators it's about what they
are and they not only give favorable
coverage to their Democrat buddies they
not oh Chris Cuomo not only helped cover
up or at least
not report on to be to be as Fair as I
can the elderly who are being killed in
these nursing homes but he actively
assisted his brother to conflict of
interest for the network it's a conflict
of interest for him personally but the
craziest thing about it was that he was
actually trying to dig up dirt on those
who were accusing his brother I think
the crap I'm surprised to hear it uh
that CNN's actually suspending him
nobody believed it was going to happen I
don't know what you guys think they got
Fredo now please do Cooper and Wolf
Blitzer please and the brain the brain
eating guy and the Brain he's gone
already but there's also a Potato Head
in there and you know other Vanderbilts
there's a lot of different people in
there but regardless of that it's
interesting to see him suspended because
it's it's also going to be interesting
to see if he got paid vacation for this
but with the way CNN has been behaving I
wouldn't be surprised if they pull off
another lube and tubing kind of incident
and he comes back in six months and then
gives kind of a half-assed apology and
then kind of continues on with his
trauma-based mind control that he kind
of spews to the General Public base so I
wouldn't be surprised if that happens a
lot of people are saying why wasn't he
fired I do think he's going to come back
but that's just my own personal opinion
later down when everything kind of dies
down yeah I I think for me I I wish I
could join in the the parade of
Celebration that and I don't like Chris
Cuomo either and I'm happy that I mean I
think he deserves to get fired it
couldn't have happened to a more
deserving guy but at the same time you
just know that they're going to replace
him with someone who's 50 times worse
it's the same thing that happened in New
York and everybody on the right was
celebrating because Andrew Cuomo uh got
the ax and I was I'm usually taking the
cynical view of things so and in that
case I'm thinking well there's a reason
why the left has decided to throw this
guy under the bus because they never
throw their own guys under the bus and
they're only going to do it if they know
they have somebody waiting the wings
who's going to be even more their
servant on the far left and so then
Kathy hockeyell gets in there and um
that's how you say your name that's how
I have no idea if that's actually hokey
will hockey I don't know but she gets in
there and she's far more far left than
uh than Cuomo was and so I you know it's
going to be the same thing I think
they're going to replace them with
someone
like their own version of Joy Reed or
something I mean CNN take a look at you
know Andrew and Chris Cuomo they're
white men
so certainly I know it's you know a
little silly to bring up but I'm willing
to bet that there are uh culty wokists
who are just like what can we do to
remove these guys and so they'll exploit
any any crisis now truth be told Andrew
Cuomo there's pictures of him grabbing
people and then my favorite thing about
his whole Scandal was he was like let me
show you all the Montage of me grabbing
more people to prove that I'd do it to
everybody and I'm like oh so he admits
it right but uh Chris as a member uh as
a staff member at CNN we all we all
assumed even yesterday talking about
this that he was going to be protected
the fact that they're suspending him
indefinitely it could mean that they're
gonna they could decide to bring him
back and say pending further review or
whatever but yeah they're gonna have to
have someone fill that slot immediately
then how much you want to bet it's going
to be someone who's particularly woke
yeah I bet there's probably some inner
politics that we don't even know about
that kind of unfolded here because to
see both Como Brothers taken down by the
establishment uh kind of shows that
there's something else happening here
that that we don't know about I mean it
was the New York attorney general that
released the private messages between
him and his brother so so obviously
something bigger here is at play I
wouldn't be surprised if it's a bigger
power move and if there was a request
for the comos to do something and then
they kind of turned it down I think
there's a possibility for that but again
we're kind of speculating here but why
did she release the text do you know for
one thing she's running for governor so
she wants his job so that's yeah that's
one thing uh but you also brought up a
good point about I didn't even think
about this but uh but tubing yeah so
Lubin tubing is officially his internet
yeah his name is tuben right yeah come
on man
somehow he survives and the thing about
that the people talk about that and they
say well he he accidentally was on
camera it was a big mishap no he didn't
know he's on camera but he didn't
accidentally fall and trip and and you
know pleasure himself
that that party did on he he knew that
he was on in him he tried to do that
during a meeting the only thing is he
didn't know that people were watching
him so that's a really serious
infraction when it comes to sexual
harassment in the workplace and somehow
he survives that at CNN and and women at
CNN have to like go into the break room
and be around this guy you know drinking
a cup of coffee knowing he's had a
meeting with other women and he's lubing
the tubing I mean and imagine your
conversations with someone it's just
sick on so many levels like how more
like perverted can you get this CNN it
is CNN it is pretty pretty a seedy Place
yeah I'm like with everything that's
gone at CNN first we got the guy who ate
the brains remember that Reza Aslan
eight human brain oh yeah yeah
Raza Aslan ate human brain then he lost
his mind and well maybe he was always
crazy yeah but he eats human brain I
just gotta say it a couple times like
people need to understand this about the
CNN hosted a show where he sat down with
a bunch of you know religious it was
like a Hindu extremist group they gave
him a small piece of brain and he ate it
yeah so you've got things like that how
do they get the brain I don't know I
don't know I have no idea I think it was
from a deceased person if I remember
correctly the video's still up on
YouTube and YouTube still actively
promotes CNN even though they cause so
much irreversible harm to female
employees and other animals I was gonna
say that too so you not only have that
you have you know Chris Cuomo and the
conflicts of interest and and you have
um Don Lemon yeah he also assaulted a
guy and well he's accused of assaulting
a guy yeah what do you do he shoved his
hands in his pants and then shoved him
in the guy's face the details are of
course contested here but it's uh you
know adult assault family-friendly show
of of another man those are the
accusation accusations against him it's
going to go uh toward in a trial soon
it's going to be divulged I want all the
details so it's going to be and now and
then we have obviously Cuomo's conflict
of interest trying to dig up dirt on the
accuses against his brother and now that
we got to get into this tube and thing
because you brought up a really good
point and I want to stress this imagine
you you are you know so here's what
happens with tube and he's in a virtual
like a zoom meeting right with a bunch
of people and he decides he's going to
crank it out while watching all of his
co-workers right and he didn't realize
his camera was still on so they
suspended they bring him back now you
brought up a really good point in the
break room but imagine this imagine you
got to call the guy and you're you're
like imagine a female employee and
they're so and they're told like oh can
you get on get a call with tubing nope
because well imagine this imagine
imagine what it would be like if you're
you know I don't care if you're a man or
a woman and you call this guy and he's
on a treadmill and like you're panting
and breathing heavy yeah tell me tell me
more about the projects I don't think he
spends a lot of time on the treadmill
tell me more how you hate Trump oh God
what are you doing and then he's like I
was set up I was I was on the chat the
whole time
getting pumped that's one way to put it
in a lot of people are laughing at I
said that the brain came from a deceased
person and people were saying yeah
obviously
yeah so there's also a lot of
[Laughter]
how did Alfredo comments in the chat
room and I think one of the best
comments that I saw about this situation
was from Danny polischuk who said
another content creator Bites the Dust
with the news of Fredo getting fired so
have you seen uh do you watch like Ryan
Long's comedy yeah yeah he uh he did a
bit with Danny Paul's Chuck I'm signing
that wrong all right
Danny's joke was call call these
journalists content creators because and
then Ryan is like you know that the
people on the the leftists journalists
will freak out and the right would be
like or whatever I'm like not really
care so I agree so I've been calling the
people at CNN content creators I'm not
gonna you know they're not journalists
well it's like the MSNBC they decided
that Rachel Maddow wasn't actually a
journalist they're like oh she's giving
too much of an opinion to be a
journalist so it's like yeah she's
basically a content creator what'd you
call it I mean you know I think it's
fine to call them pundits yeah you know
what I mean but content creator is is
meant to like Ryan Nails it you know
it's gonna drive them crazy and none of
us would care to be called like oh
whatever I like the old school kind of
prostitutes I think that has a nice ring
to it personally myself but I think
universally if we just all started
calling them content creators it would
really bother them and get underneath
their skin so I think we should
normalize this and implement this rule
this kind of unsmoking rule like hey if
we're gonna refer to these people one we
shouldn't be calling them the mainstream
media the other corporate media too
they're not journalists they're content
creators yeah and um CNN's media content
creator Brian stelter of course will
eventually run a segment being like the
new attack from the right referring to
hard-working journalists content
creators and then he'd have yeah
Republican sponsor and they'd have like
a round table of like you know the
strategy here is really to diminished
the world the role we do and holding
power to account and speaking truth to
power and yeah remember when they
compare themselves to like active
military members CNN did this they're
like yeah we're the best it's like 2015.
it's Ryan Williams did that perfectly
too it's a good it's a good point too
because I I actually wouldn't
care the bias and all that kind of stuff
it wouldn't bother me if we if they were
just called something else the fact that
they claim to be journalists is the
problem because the thing is we hear
everyone complain about oh bias and the
media the media's always been biased you
go back and read like uh headlines from
newspapers during the Civil War era and
it's just it's it's extremely partisan
the difference is back then they didn't
pretend otherwise they embraced the fact
that we have a point of view so the
problem with CNN is that they if they
would just admit that look we come from
a left-wing perspective this is what we
care about this is our perspective then
fine do your thing just don't pretend
otherwise it's weird though I mean
I don't think the the current Left Right
phrasing you know I've said this for a
while it makes literally no sense but I
I've kind of come to an understanding
the real the reality is there are two
realities and so I think all of us in
this room exist in one political Compass
reality and that is honest and true
reality of course we believe that that's
why we're all sitting here but what I
mean is you know we fact check things
um we try to make sure we get things
right good example the Covington kids
this big fake news you know thing thrown
on the media or Kyle Rittenhouse we're
the kind of people whether we agree or
disagree on certain political policies
or or you know certain uh you know
economic policies we all agree on what
is real because we've looked at and said
oh okay Trump didn't really do anything
wrong when he was throwing the food into
the koi pond he was just doing what
Shinzo Abe did but then you have this
other political Compass of people who
live in the matrix it's almost like a
blue pill red pill political Compass so
it's funny when you see these people
will say like this show is right wing
what they're really saying is they exist
in a separate reality because I
certainly think I'm to the left to view
Matt you know and like we can agree on
the truth but we probably disagree on
policy positions but we can sit here and
have conversation because we agree on
what is real so that's kind of the point
you like to talk about the leftists and
to mention CNN well populist socialist
types would be like CNN is not left wing
they're a right wing it's like no no no
hold on in your bubble world yeah yeah
CNN is is the right wing in the fake
reality they live in the corporate press
is authoritarian and right wing so it's
almost like they have their own scale of
right and left that's right yeah yeah so
they're like um this is CNN is right
wing and everything else I think it was
you Matt that was talking I think
yesterday about having a curated reality
I think you mentioned a Truman Show it's
a great comparison yeah I like content
creator I kind of stumbled on this thing
yesterday that uh another way of looking
at the corporate media is that their
reality curators and uh and that's a lot
of what they do they don't necessarily
lie and well they do plenty of lying but
most of the time they're not like
pretending something happened when it
didn't really happen again they do that
but but more often the bias comes from
deciding what to tell us about what bits
of reality to bring to our attention and
um and yeah I think about that scene in
uh in in The Truman Show which I brought
up when uh the director was asked like
why hasn't Truman ever questioned his
reality and the director said well we we
accept uh the reality of the world that
we're presented
um and and there's a lot of Truth to
that that you just kind of accepted also
that word presented is important because
that's how most of us it's not that
we're like encountering reality or
discovering it we kind of sit back and
we stare at our screens all day and we
have reality presented to us we have
people usually corporate media telling
us well this is reality this is what's
true but it's all it's all curated based
on what they want us to believe and so
Waukesha for example is a good example
of something that that doesn't fit into
the reality that they want us to
understand so that doesn't make it in
they don't curate that for us well they
very simply just say an SUV you know hit
people an accident caused by an SUV but
I'll point out too just a side note on
The Truman Show thing uh it's a good
point we don't we don't question the
result reality presented in The Truman
Show he starts to notice things like he
goes into a building and there's no
elevator it's a set but if if he was
born there and his whole life was seeing
that kind of stuff he'd never question
it he'd be like oh another Studio set
behind an elevator I see him all the
time yeah well there's a reason they
call it programming and I think there's
something to say about Echo Chambers and
the carefully curated algorithms that
give us information that that of course
enforce a particular Viewpoint and the
power that big Tech social media has
they have the will to impose people's
perceptions and ideas and there should
definitely be a bigger discussion about
this but earlier Tim I think you said
something that definitely uh is
important to talk about is that it's not
really left and right it's it's whether
you believe in authoritarianism or if
you believe in Freedom I think that's
the true kind of bigger political
compass that people should be talking
about that people should be
understanding and when it comes to even
calling them content creators I think
that's given them too much credit
because they're not creating content
they're regurgitating repeating
corporatist talking points that of
course special interests feed them and
they just regurgitate it back to the
general public we know but content
creator is meant to irk them yes maybe
corporate content regurgitator or a
Creator I don't know look when it comes
to the different political compasses you
know idea of like the the blue pill
false reality within the corporate press
I I don't think that adequately explains
you know uh the phenomenon we're
experiencing with the culture work
because I've I've thought about that
maybe it's just the libertarian spectrum
of course we all agree you know if I'm
I'm more about freedom but I lean left
and you're about Freedom we'll probably
get along but if you're authoritarian
we're not going to get along but I have
I have a a friend actually we have his
painting up where is it um you can't see
it's off camera because I've had people
be like I don't believe Tim has any
left-wing friends like oh no Brett's
really cool and he made this a comic
book called Snow White Zombie Apocalypse
that I've helped Kickstart a couple
times because I think it's fantastic
really really great art cool story it's
not super political or anything but you
know we were having a discussion about
Kyle Rittenhouse and he's very much in
the corporate press version of what Kyle
right now was doing he was posting on
Facebook saying the prosecution's case
is super strong I was surprised he was
repeating the prosecutions talking
points you'd probably hear on MSNBC or
things like that and we were talking
about it you know he said uh we got to
this point where he said something I was
talking about the prison system it being
broken anyway and I don't understand why
he would be on the side of the state in
this regard and he was like the state is
illegitimate and I was like okay well
hold on there a minute I was like we can
agree on almost everything we come to
this point where we're like when you say
the state is illegitimate I'll be a bit
facetious and say we agree on that and
what I mean is like we disregard the
establishment the authority and the lies
in the manipulation but when you're in
this different version of reality we
don't we we can't work together towards
like solving any problem because his
version of reality is you know Kyle
Rittenhouse was a violent reactionary
who showed up to to hurt protesters and
I'm like but that's just not true
if you live in the in the world of the
corporate press it doesn't matter if you
think the state is illegitimate and
you're an anarchist you live in a false
reality where your motivations are
fueled by incorrect information leading
to leading you to cheer for the state
like like he was doing so I mean that
with with all due respect you know I I
think he's a cool dude but there we we
very seriously disagree on what is even
true or not yeah as curation like you
were saying these companies basically
curating what we see defects when people
they're going to be able to be like
they're going to show you something
that's not real and they're going to
tell you it's real and then they're
going to be able to be like we wash our
hands of it we received it we checked it
out it looked real to us we were just
reporting on what we thought was real
and then people are going to be seeding
all these deep fakes that are like it
might even be the news organizations
that create the depicts we find later
but then they're just telling us they
didn't know they were fake Spider-Man
yeah Spider-Man three what about it Sam
Ramey's yeah yeah so you've got the
dancing one yes okay yes so um uh I
bring this up because it was on TV and I
happen to have seen it but there's a
really there's a scene where Eddie
Barack is the character who wants to be
a staff photographer Peter Parker is has
been a freelance photographer there for
years
so Eddie Brock is sucking up to Jameson
who's the the editor-in-chief or the the
whatever position he has
and he says whoever gets me a photo of
Spider-Man with his hand in the cookie
jar gets the job so what does Brock do
he photoshops an image of Spider-Man
committing a crime they run it on the
front page he gets hired they later find
out they have to retract I think it's a
stretch you know for you know if in real
life they probably wouldn't retract
they'd just be like like you said well
we were reporting the truth at the time
so there you go but uh as much as it's a
silly fictional example of this I bring
it up because that's what happens you
have quote unquote journalists who are
like I need to move up in this company I
need to get traffic you know there are a
lot of companies that pay their writers
based on how much how many clicks they
get oh wow like this is this is Gawker
Gawker was Notorious for like get a
bunch of views you get you get paid more
money a lot of right-wing websites do
the exact same thing what are you gonna
get you're gonna get people trying to
write as as clickbaity Sensational stuff
as they can and eventually you'll find
people who here's a good example you
ever see the movie Nightcrawler yeah
amazing movie Jake Gyllenhaal and he
he's a sociopath trying to find a way to
make money and he stumbles upon late
night crawling it's when you go out in
the middle of the night and track down
crimes fires crashes hurt people and
things like that and he begins actually
staging like he he act I don't want to
ruin the movie because it's so good but
he's a nasty sociopath who stages some
of these photos you get these people in
media then you give them the virtue
signal ability to like pretend to be
political and they will run with it now
they've got a safety net a barrier to
where they can make things up write
garbled nonsense to get massive clicks
make money and they're protected when
they do it why because they're on the
right side of History so they say
they're not just Protected Their
competition is eliminated and of course
fact checked into Oblivion and
downranked in the algorithm where you
can't even see them even if you're
subscribed to them I think it was
BuzzFeed that had an infographic at
their office Studio showing the articles
that are getting the most amount of
shares and a live number update graphic
showing everyone working there what's
what's getting the clicks what's not
getting the clicks and once you kind of
involve yourself into pleasing the
algorithm you're involved in pleasing of
course the agenda of the people who are
creating the algorithm who's creating
the algorithm who's running the
algorithms what's the response and
result of these algorithms well I think
superficially we could look at it and
see there's a lot of depression there's
a lot more suicide there's a lot more
self-hate there's a lot of other
psychological issues that are
encroaching and becoming more of a
problem every single day and when we
look at these algorithms they rule Our
Lives because they roll perceptions and
understandings and once you have control
of that in my opinion you have control
of everything and that's why the world
is in one factor so messed up as it is
right now because of this tightly
controlled small Viewpoint that that
they're doing everything in their power
to make sure that you don't see outside
of it and when you do you see that it's
full of crap yeah absolutely and now one
of the things that I was noticing today
was that Twitter I know we were talking
yesterday about how they're new CEO
might be worse than the old one it turns
out that this is definitely going to be
the case because one of the things that
they're going to do is like remove the
right of these independent journalists
to post material that's not approved
right so it's going to be a serious
issue as far as Journal actual
journalism because I really feel like
The Rittenhouse trial was such a Triumph
for a place like the Daily Caller people
who right-wing journalists who are
actually on the ground and like unbiased
journalists who really went out there
and did the work so I feel like
Twitter's really twisting it yeah Dorsey
is not the demon that he had been made
out to be he was he was like has five
percent of Twitter and was like
basically holding on for dear life
trying to make it something useful the
day leaves and the new CEOs like here's
what real Authority is yeah maybe so I
think I I think the challenge we face at
least to kind of like wrap up this
portion of like the content curators and
the the corporate press and all that
stuff
it's it's getting through to people
you know it's it's finding that regular
person who maybe doesn't pay attention
and being able to pitch them on their
own intrinsic value life liberty and
happiness but they have to want it so
when you have people who just say look
man I just want to fit in they're going
to walk right to you know uh to Brian
stelter or whatever you know other
content creators at CNN and just say
tell me what to think and I'll think it
because I just want to fit in so how do
we convince people be your own person
stand up for yourself
I don't know maybe you can't maybe
what's really happening is a sorting
algorithm of people who just want to
follow and people who who want to be
independent and I think the other really
what we're talking about the real
division is uh we're now living in a in
a country where there's basically two
different at least two different
realities that we're living in and uh
two different universes really so when
we when people talk about are we headed
towards a civil war that sort of thing I
think we're not just because
for a civil war you need a you need like
a geographic divide which which there
isn't as much right now as there was in
uh in in 1861 I would say but I do think
that we're more divided than we were in
the Civil War
um the conditions are there in that
sense because we just when you when you
get a hundred Americans into a room from
all over the country and you start
talking to them
um you'll find that they don't they have
absolutely nothing in common at all at
no level like you talk to them about
their fundamental priorities and values
what things do they care about the most
all that kind of stuff you're going to
find that um there's almost no Common
Thread bringing them all together no no
commonality no nothing uniting us and
there has to be something some uniting
principle and there isn't it's uh it's
two different moral Frameworks at the
end of the day right you have the the uh
Christian judeo-christian moral
framework and then you have this new
wokeest moral framework which is
completely removed from it so one of the
ways I explain it to people is uh Bill
Maher is a great example clearly a
person who was raised on Christian moral
values even though he's an atheist so he
believes in free speech he believes in
innocent until proven guilty Concepts
that are in the Bible so in America a
lot of our foundational rights
inalienable rights granted by God that
was the perception of the founding
fathers even people who were growing up
in the 80s 90s and becoming prominent
might not believe in any of that stuff
but they hold those moral Frameworks
still within them from their their the
Traditions that they were handed they
were given but now you have a new moral
framework completely removed from all
those values they don't believe in the
right of the innocent until proven
guilty you know they're they're
something completely separate if they
even have a moral framework I do want to
mention though uh I disagree with you on
the need for a geographical divide
that's uh um that's an American
perspective on Civil War if you look at
a lot of other countries Spanish Civil
War is a really good example they didn't
have a geographic geographical divide in
the same way they had cities versus the
rural areas rural nationalists and urban
Communists so I believe that's what it
was I believe the Communists were
centered around cities I could be wrong
but it was it was essentially fascists
and Communists and if you look at the
initial battle maps where the ideology
started getting power it was splotchy it
was like the left-wing group was here
then it was over here and they were not
United or connected in any way so we we
actually that we do have in the United
States but in America the Civil War here
was based on you know we have each
individual State siding on a specific
you know states rights slavery versus
you know more united Federalist power
which ultimately resulted in States
breaking apart and then the interesting
thing I think it was uh Texas was like
we have no choice because we're
surrounded by Southern States who hold
this hold these values we we wouldn't be
able to be on the side anyway so in that
sense I I think there's a there's a you
know you're sort of correct that yeah I
sort of agree with you that's a good
point so I guess I would go to my my
other my other reason why I don't think
there's actually a civil war is that uh
nobody wants to leave their air
conditioning and their TV for very long
like we all we all there's just there's
not the there's not the wear with all
the will for that sort of thing but but
I still fun I still disagree
um you know are you familiar with the
fourth turning the straw side
generational Theory stuff no so they say
it's like every 80 years as a conflict
we had the American Revolution eight
years later the Civil War 80 years later
you know World War II now it's 80 years
later and you know what are we expecting
to see in this fourth turning period
there's four separate you know 20-year
periods I'm not saying that's
definitively true but I certainly think
we're headed towards a period of great
strife and I think that one of the other
challenges with civil war is that people
believe
they they look to history to get example
of what war is and so we look back at
the American Civil War and see people
fighting we look back at World War II
and people are running through the
fields but we're in the era of social
media manipulation and its fourth and
fifth generational Warfare so they're
using propaganda using corporate press
they're using censorship using economic
control they don't need to point a
weapon at you to convince you to do
something if they can take away your
ability to communicate with anyone else
or make you think that a weapon's being
pointed at you even though it's not or
you're going to face some repercussions
if you commit wrong think and Matt you
made a very good point we are very
comfortable we are very blessed we are
very lucky you notice that especially if
you travel the world and you compare our
lifestyles to how everyone else is
living but that is rapidly changing
right now especially with the economic
turmoil that's being created by the
centralization of economic forces by the
federal government by the Federal
Reserve that I believe deliberately is
trying to create havoc on the world
economic Market that is creating not
only inflation shrink inflation meat
flation but just the utter devaluation
of the US dollar and I think soon
America will have to live like the rest
of the world I think there will be a
shock and in that shock in that kind of
larger transform of wealth that has been
happening since the beginning of this
pandemic I do think there's a potential
for conflict I hope it doesn't happen
I'm not saying it is going to happen but
I think there is a window where that
potential opens especially with the
economic Havoc coming our way which I
believe is deliberately being pushed on
by a lot of centralized big powerful
Players let's talk about the the Twitter
thing that you know Lydia just
responsive second ago we have the story
from timcast.com Twitter announces new
expansion of its private information
policy the announcement has been noted
for its vague Language by Twitter users
so this is uh basically media that they
deem to be private will be
banned they can now ban you and they say
in the rules explicitly that if you are
not abusing someone then they can still
remove you now because they have a new
rule set this will mean independent
journalists it will mean that reporters
on the ground who happen to be filming
certain activists doing something will
get all of that content removed they
then came out and said well we'll
clarify we'll clarify
um if it's a big protest or it's
newsworthy we'll consider the context
what does that mean Andy know is a great
example and you know is a journalist and
the left absolutely despises him because
he reports on what antifa and these
other individuals are doing so naturally
Twitter's probably going to say oh this
is exposing activists and it's really
dangerous because they literally in
their rules say activists dissidents
women and minorities are the most
vulnerable now if you met for instance
you went to Loudoun County right and you
spoke there yet they're not going to
protect you
they're they're gonna say you know if if
a video comes out of you and you say hey
look this is a private video from an
event it's really bad for me as an
activist they're gonna say shut your
mouth they're gonna say oh you don't
count you're not an activist and you
know is not a journalist he doesn't
deserve any protections I kind of feel
like this is an expansion of their
policy that they informally put in place
with the hunter Biden stuff because
wasn't their argument that this was
acquired through you know untoward means
or whatever like through actions
illegally obtained I mean they just
should have saved everyone some time and
just said future project Veritas will no
longer be allowed on the platform that
would have been more honest because if
you look at who this is going to affect
it's going to be investigative
journalists muck Rikers it's literally
Veritas yes it's literally I mean they
just should have said this policy no
more project Veritas videos on top of
people sharing those videos it's done
that's it it's also people are
parsing this on Twitter and saying what
does this mean what about this what
about that well it's it's that's the
point it's the ambiguity is the point
it's supposed to be vague because then
that gives them the ability to decide so
they they can just kind of decide well
yeah we're gonna get rid of project
Veritas We're not gonna let another
writtenhouse situation happen ever again
they're saying uh where these videos
come out to expose the truth but then of
course because the other thing is well
what about all these cop videos I mean
the George Floyd video uh Derek Chauvin
did not did not consent to having that
video out there but we can we can assume
that all the cop videos are gonna still
be allowed uh but they'll just be able
to decide in a moment and that's exactly
what they're setting themselves
themselves up for it's it's the
increasing movement towards homogenizing
our culture once again so it used to be
we had a few media channels everybody
listened to Walter Cronkite just
believed whatever he said whether it was
true or not everyone assumed it was it
was true and then with the birth of the
internet we had all of these different
voices rising up boy did they get mad
when Alex Jones was getting hundreds of
millions of views we never approved this
guy so saith the establishment so they
get rid of them they get rid of Milo
they get rid of Laura learn where they
get rid of all these undesirables now
they got to connect with the fact that
they're still dissident voices that are
doing pretty well because people want
and crave freedom and honesty and
information oh so they'll want to get
rid of us they don't they don't like
that you know we have a show where we
challenge The Establishment so what
we're going to see with this with
Twitter's you know policy is Project
Veritas gotta go Andy knows reporting
gotta go if we do it we did a story on
uh fauci's uh uh the Nia the niaid
funding monkey maximum pain experiments
although oh no you can't publish those
photos or they information about fauci
it's private information they will just
decide they've already done it with the
hunter Biden laptop story they don't
care about hacked information tons of
hacked information has come up they
don't block it now they're just
formalizing the rule and letting you
know the end result of this is over the
next several years eventually everyone
will just be watching CNN
a lot of people say CNN's ratings are in
the gutter CNN got 100 million views on
YouTube this month
we on this show I think got like 25
right Tim cast altogether maybe has like
40. so it's that's great that's that's
awesome CNN is being given a hundred
million views we fight for that we we
work every day we tell everyone we bag
we drop on we get down and we say please
listen or share this video because we
aren't being promoted the way CNN is by
YouTube and they get free money free
promotion you're thriving in spite of
everything that YouTube it's the same
thing the daily wire you know right
where I work in the daily wire uh we do
really well on Facebook and uh the the
the Medias the corporate media is always
putting out these uh these like exposes
about oh look how well the daily wires
look on Facebook obviously obviously
Facebook uh favors right-wing content or
what look what look what Facebook is
doing to help out the daily wire it's
absurd of course we're doing well in
spite of everything Facebook has done to
uh to stifle it but this is just their
their way of getting rid of the the
competition they don't like the fact
that that we do the reason why we do
well is be because people actually want
this content because they're looking for
just common sense and truth and that
sort of thing it may be that um you know
we are waiting through the muck and the
mire and the the water seems to be
rising trying to hold you know hold us
back but they're losing they're losing
uh when I look at how how ex explosive
the daily wire has been like what you
guys have been doing they can't stop you
you're gonna you're gonna shatter
through that they set up this barrier
trying to hold you guys back but you're
breaking through CNN is on life support
it's like they're on a gurney being
wheeled out in the front of the White
House and they're like everyone's like
hey look put all the cameras on CNN
right now and it's like
it's obvious that that's a dying art
form yeah there's this episode of The
Outer Limits where this really old guy
you know death is trying to take him to
the other side but he keeps he's super
rich so he pays people to like keep
giving him new hearts and he's on like a
sixth heart transplant that's CNN yes
they're just like like Ian explained it
but it's worse than that they're like
all decrepit another thing to really
kind of think about here is that a lot
of CNN viewers are force-fed CNN people
have to go out and find alternative
media people have to go out and find Tim
cast daily wire we are change and and
that in itself is a huge victory that
we're still able to survive when of
course in the Cyber gulags they're
literally shoving it down your throats
and people are still spitting it out and
saying wait wait hold on there has to be
something better uh there has to be
something more nutritious for my body
and my mind out there that actually has
some semblance of Truth and
responsibility in it and that's when
they find other people that and and
they're making it more and more
difficult for for them to find us but
people still are yeah because I think
that the corporate media is really
fighting with a free market right now
which is really interesting to me
because they're trying to throttle it
and I'm a little bit concerned that the
next step is going to be something like
a Government monopoly like that
genuinely concerns me watching the
collusion between the Democrats and the
corporate Medias Luke it reminds us to
call it it's very very troubling to me
to watch and see the reflection that
like the parents in Loudoun County are
talking about how this very much reminds
me of the cultural evolution in China
and I can't imagine that the government
was exactly you know easy on the media
when they were trying to compel every
single person in the country to come
conform with their will so I'm not sure
what the next step is but it's a little
a little bit unsettling yeah that media
Crackdown you got to watch out for that
I've explained I've explained it several
times is this there's there's this big
island we're on it's just sheer cliff on
all sides and you have people on the
right side of this the waves crash the
Clifford roads and and the far right
falls into the ocean what's next is
conservatives the waves crash the
Clifford roads the conservatives all
Fallen then you've got you know moderate
slightly centered right individuals then
the Centrist and what's left is going to
be people who believe anyone to the
right of Mao is far right yes that's
who's going to be left standing exactly
or to be fair a gigantic corporate you
know monolith saying you guys are useful
idiots for us we accept that well I'm a
little bit concerned because I'm going
to make kind of an esoterographic
ref but I think William Butler Yates
where he uh it's called the second
coming and he talks about how the worst
of are full of like
this
ridiculous intention and they have a
strong desire to commit these worst acts
and the best are just like silent and he
says in that poem that the center cannot
hold that is so interesting to me
because I've heard the expression you
know if you stay in the center of the
road you get going to get run over so I
wonder if these values at the center
holds it's possible that the edges are
being whittled away enough and that
their beliefs are weak enough that
they're just gonna you know there was a
there was a left and a right in this
country
and it started to split further and
further apart there's an amazing graphic
by uh graph by Pew research where it
shows from 1994 until today how the left
and right have moved and the right has
moved like a teeny bit to the right and
the left has shot super far left
at at that point you know I always
thought it's like okay well we're really
polarized when when in reality what
actually happened is it got so far that
it broke off into two different
realities yeah and there's that's the
thing there's no there is no a center or
moderate position anymore because in
between that is sort of like a an abyss
and you look at any the the issue that
I've written this book about Johnny
wallers johnnywals.com uh is is just
like this because there's a question
here okay of can a four-year-old boy
uh be a girl if he says that he is and
the answer to that question is either
yes or no there's there's no in between
well I'm kind of moderate on that
um biology your biological sex that's
either a reality or it's not and uh so
many issues are like this now where it's
you have you really have to choose it's
a time of choosing and you have to
decide I'm I'm either on the side of
reality or not I don't think there's a
moderate position this is what's been
happening I mean this is a really good
example that there uh when you had um
who was that Professor who was debating
Jordan Peterson Nicholas Matt was that
his name yeah that person so uh this
professor was in Canada said there's no
such thing as biological sex that's
that's that's a misconception and I
would break that down but in the
interest of time I won't there are
people who genuinely say things like
that now
as we were talking about earlier people
don't question their reality so if you
have people who are born being told the
moon is made of cheese their whole life
they would never question it it's it's
you know the interesting thing about uh
I grew up Catholic uh uh for several
years and then my family left the church
but I actually could understand
faith-based arguments on the nature of
reality why well
there's a lot of great philosophers in
in many of these religions so when you
actually come with a really uh with a
with an actual religion many of them I
think are kind of you know out there
some of them have very interesting
intelligent thinkers then I look at
wokism and it's just garbled nonsense
that makes no sense but these people act
as though they're part of a giant
religion it's a non-theistic religion no
yeah I I think I I would even draw I
don't know if this is a real
definitional distinction or not but I
like there's a difference between a
religion and a cult and um I I would
look at wokis or whatever we want to
call them it's more of a cult it's kind
of like Scientology because the thing
about a religion to say the Christian
religion for example is that um it has a
lot to say about the world about human
nature that that even if you're not part
of that religion you can still
understand and gain something from you
don't have to be a Christian to read the
gospels and and derive something from it
and find it quite beautiful and useful
uh whereas this woke is stuff I mean I
just on on my show I read uh there was
this I forget who shared it but it was
um a mass a gender studies Masters
thesis that from the University of of
wisconsin-milwaukee that uh someone
found online and they just shared it and
just the intro of it and it's it's woke
you know CRT garbage but it makes no
sense at all it's totally it's this like
inseal insular thing where you have to
be in it to even understand what they're
talking about so if you're not with with
a real religion you can gain some wisdom
from it either even if you're adding it
with the cult like Scientology you have
to be in it first to uh be indoctrinated
into their kind of logic to even know
what the hell they're trying to say it's
non-white is a good word you got to
learn the definition of it's how you can
start to understand like and one one
phrase that was used in this thing was
that was the phrase anti-racist racist
not just right it means nothing it makes
no sense but you have to be first you
have to be indoctrinated into the cult
first and then you kind of can make
sense of it this is kind of what I you
know I was meaning to get to right like
or trying to explain with uh a good
example is V for Vendetta love this
movie when Evie goes to that comedian's
house and he shows her his secret you
know room where he's got I think it's
gay porn or something like that yeah
because he's like if the police found
out it had this yeah and uh she also
says is that a Quran she's like but
you're you're not Muslim and he says I
don't need to be Muslim to find its
stories moving or it's imagery beautiful
or something like that and that's that
that's a great Point uh I don't think
you have to believe in in the religion
to read it and understand some of the
ideas to agree or disagree with some of
these things but when I've tried reading
woke science like woke these you know
reports or whatever or like scientific I
don't know Humanities whatever you call
academic stuff academic studies it's
like they'll say something like
extrapolating the anti-whiteness of
white reasoning in white supremacist
agriculture through the medieval
archetypes and you're like
it doesn't mean anything it doesn't mean
you need to learn the language no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no what
I'm saying is quite literally it doesn't
mean anything and what you get are
people mindlessly saying things that
don't mean anything to each other just
to try and sound like they know more
than they do it's meant yeah it's meant
to confuse you it's meant to have you in
this state of like what's going on two
plus two equals five yes it is of course
it is yes just tell me what you believe
in beyond that it's it's to go like this
Luke Luke you know uh you you clearly
don't understand look when I wrote my
thesis on the archetypal white
supremacist anti-racist racist uh
conflating with with antifa and the
wimixin of Northern medieval tribes you
if you don't understand that then
certainly you must step back and give me
the room in the floor to speak because
you are not an expert here as an
official person of color I decline your
uh well
I'm mixed race well that doesn't matter
I think I'm on the hierarchy here
actually that's true so uh so you lose I
don't know if you know this but uh the
Coalition for communities of color have
said that Slavic people are people of
color really so blonde hair blue eyed
blue gradkowski is a person of color
Polo congratulations Polish porn thank
you very much I I have my card I
laminated it and I've been using it ever
since so actually for your struggles
thank you Ian look I do defer to you on
the Progressive stack because I'm
actually uh German Irish British and
then part Korean so I'm actually more
white and you're Slavic so you're all
you know 100 person of color exactly so
I definitely treat you on that but I'll
stop speaking I'll just give you thank
you very much I mean we should call this
show what it what it is you know the
radowski hour but anyway what it is it's
also screeching it's also a lot of
emotion it's also a lot of manipulation
and there's also No Redemption in this
kind of Church of the cult that's being
promoted on individuals that is
absolutely just spewing nonsense and I
think this nonsense is done deliberately
in order to acquiesce the general public
into compliance into having them on
their knees literally saying yes I will
obey whatever crazy wombs you decide for
me because when you have someone at a
state where they don't even know what
they believe in you have a state where
they could be very easily controlled and
manipulated at the whim of a mob that of
course is also manipulated on social
media and
um and and weaponized in a way where it
creates people's actions to be
manipulated by them so so I think that's
an aspect here that we also should
entertain with big text involvement in
the kind of pushing of this cult I saw
this hilarious like meme I guess and it
said capitalism everybody is poor and a
few people are rich communism nobody
nobody is Rich a few party members
control everything socialism ever
anybody can be rich but nobody is ever
poor and I was just like man these
people are insane but that's you know I
bring that up because the goal is
communism and socialism what's the
difference honestly very little but
there's a distinction right socialism is
the economic system communism is more
the political system both are
effectively the same thing the means of
production are owned by the people what
tends to happen is the same thing
powerful Elites gain control of
everything and then everyone is poor and
suffers and centralized planning doesn't
work but they use language manipulation
to be like we're not Communists in
socialism no one's poor it's literally
said that the end goal of socialism is
always communism and I believe this to
be the case based on what socialism does
like it's very very similar that's how
they manipulate with language I know
they're good let's let's jump to this
next story and get into uh you know just
I guess some of the goings on and uh the
story scares me this is the Kim Potter
trial manslaughter charge in Taser Taser
Taser shooting just death of Dante right
so the news today is they're doing jury
selection the story is important because
this is what happens when you start
losing your your core moral framework so
one of the things we were just talking
about is the judeo-christian moral
framework how within it I believe you
know in the past there were some you
know a lot of bad ideas in culture but a
lot of good ideas persisted a lot of bad
ideas felt you know were uh no longer
carried on and that's that's that's good
news we have free speech we have life
liberty The Pursuit of Happiness we have
individual liberties we have the
innocent until proven guilty and uh a
lot of people don't know this but the
the concept of being innocent until
proven guilty is literally in the Bible
and the formulation of this idea
expanded throughout history blackstone's
formulation is better the 10 guilty
persons Escape than one innocent person
suffer to Benjamin Franklin it is better
than a hundred guilty persons Escape
than one innocent person suffer
literally comes from the story of Sodom
and Gomorrah if there's one righteous
person I will not destroy the you know
the city or you probably know better
than I do Matt I bring this up as we get
into the story because as we begin
losing these values to a cult as I like
to call it I think I don't know Matt you
refer to him basically the same way uh
They Don't Care About Justice they don't
care about what's right they just say we
want retribution and we want you to
suffer so what happens in the shooting
of Dante Wright is a police officer was
trying to arrest a man on a felony
weapons charge warrant the dude breaks
free and jumps into his car she yells
Taser Taser Taser but pulls out her gun
shoots him he drives off crashes dies
from the gunshot wound she would have
been Justified most I think most legal
experts say if someone's wanted an a
felony weapons charge and fleas and
jumps in their vehicle about to grab
something then the police are justified
in assuming that's a deadly threat but
because she said taser and because he
said it was an accident she's getting
charged with manslaughter like many of
the trials we've seen so far with
Rittenhouse with Chauvin with Ahmed
Arbury all of these cases are political
are not based in whether or not we are
going to try and find the facts it's
based on whether or not we can win in
the Public's jurors the uh the
businesses they're all going to say just
give the left what they want I gotta say
if the cop was justified in killing this
guy deadly weapons charge he dives into
his car Assuming he's going to grab it
everywhere if she yells out I love you
before she shoots him it's no different
than yelling out garble garblego or
Taser Taser doesn't matter what you yell
out when you're using Justified deadly
force beforehand agreed yeah the other
thing to keep in mind and you almost you
already know this based on the track
record but the one thing we know about
BLM Martyrs especially the ones from
George Floyd and on is that almost all
of them are um have a history of of
really horrific violent crime and almost
always against women so Dante Wright is
no exception there
um I think it was it was a felony
weapons charge that he was wanted on but
that also stemmed from or was related to
an armed robbery where he you know
allegedly
um put a gun to a woman and robbed her
and also committed sexual assault by the
way because he stuffed his hand into a
bra looking for the I guess for the
money and uh so sexual and shelter so so
very similar to what George Floyd did
you know barging into a woman's house
forcing his way into a woman's house at
gunpoint robbing her uh so Dante Wright
did that as well allegedly and um and so
we know that and and also the other
thing is I look at this as
from Kim Potter's perspective you know I
would I would equate it almost to like a
medical error or something that uh that
uh that maybe would happen with a surge
people die from medical errors all the
time sometimes it's Reckless and then
you get litigation surgery people die
from medical errors all the time
sometimes it's Reckless and then you get
litigation but oftentimes it's just it's
a life or death situation surgeons are
human beings they're not perfect
it's not always going to go the right
way we just sort of understand that we
can't lock surgeons in jail every single
time a surgery doesn't go the right way
and uh so in this I look at it's kind of
a light she's she's thrust into this
life or death situation that she didn't
create Dante Wright created it number
one by being you know a felon and wanted
on a warrant number two by fighting the
cop so now he has taken what what could
what should have just been a normal
interaction where he says okay I'm gonna
go with you unwanted on a warrant and
that's it and I'll go to jail
um but he he turns it into this life or
death struggle he decided to do that and
then she makes a mistake in the midst of
that
um and it's unfortunate that she did but
the idea that now we're going to put you
in jail for that I think is uh is absurd
she knows she she's heard on the body
camera footage saying I'm going to
prison and I think the reason she said
that is because of the political
landscape so my attitude you know what
really bugged me is when all of these
leftists came out and started saying
defund the police my attitude was like
cops you just quit but none of them
would do it
as bad as it had gotten now I understand
when activists go and say you know bow
to the police or whatever you ignore it
when they say abolish the police then
start burning down police departments
and then Kamala Harris fundraises for
them and Joe Biden wins an election
after his staff had been bailing these
people out and 25 people die you went to
a point where you're kind of like maybe
you should give the people what they
want and a bunch of people on the left
got mad at me for saying it because I
was like abolish the police okay and
he's only saying that because he thinks
people will be upset after they realize
what happens when the police are gone
and I'm like maybe but does it matter if
I agree with you so when I see Kim
Potter and even she seems to know the
political ramifications of what's
happening today and they still want to
remain cops the problem I have is that
the people of Minneapolis the people in
Minnesota the people in New York will
not stand up for the officers
and then the officers get thrown to the
bus they go to prison for these things
and I'm just like give if the people of
these towns are unwilling to take
responsibility for their own communities
maybe they should be given a defunded
police department to see what happens
maybe then they'll realize and they'll
change their vote wasn't this officer
correct me if I'm wrong on desk Duty her
entire career and because of defunding
efforts she was put on on duty here and
what do you guys make of the argument
saying that she should have never been
there and that she should be held
responsible for making that accident
because it clearly does seem like she
was going after a taser but she went
after a firearm she didn't have much
experience in the field do you think
there should be some kind of
accountability for that or what's your
rebuttal against people talking about I
think if you look if if she's obviously
done on the force and so okay fine
um so there's accountability there but
but I I would stick by this that he as
Dante right as the wanted criminal and
no they didn't arrest him I think what
was the original story they told us that
he was arrested for like an air
freshener or something some totally
bogus right BS it wasn't that at all he
was he was a wanted criminal and he was
was they were she was trying to arrest
him he he is the one who decided to
escalate this and turn it into a life or
death he he put his life on the line he
decided to do that that was his decision
when you start fighting and physically
struggling with a cop that's what's
gonna happen that doesn't mean that the
cop has every right to just pull out a
gun and shoot you no matter what but um
the moment that you especially as a
wanted felon on a weapons charge the
moment that you decide to make that
decision you have now taken your life
and your hands on I don't think that we
should put all that onus on on Kim
Potter no I agree and let's throw it to
uh Kyle Rittenhouse Joseph Rosenbaum
threatened and then decided to attack a
young man carrying a rifle he created
the danger tyrannos didn't do it Karen
has fled from the attack and tried to
get away and then zavinsky fired the gun
I think when we look a lot of these
stories the the the there's a big factor
in whether or not not the individual was
the person who instigated or created the
harm now of course the left is now lying
about first they lied here he was pulled
over for an air freshener the cops it
was unjust because they need the cops to
be the ones who created the danger when
in reality we know this story is not the
case we know Kyle right now didn't
create the danger and then I'll throw it
to the Ahmed Arbury case Ahmed Arbury
ran towards the truck where the Travis
McMichael was under the shotgun flanked
him around the truck and then grabbed
the shotgun from him yeah so whether or
not you know I think there if if the
question of the citizens arrest in that
regard is that it was not legal then
yeah you can't stop someone while armed
it's false imprisonment it's a felony
and then if the person dies that's
felony murder but what we also have to
consider that Ahmed Arbury was the one
who tried grabbing the shotgun for him
creating that danger now in that one
it's a little more complicated because
you can argue the danger was created by
the McMichaels for trying to stop him
that's why I think that one's a little
more murky and nuanced But ultimately
ultimately my point is I think we
typically say we side with those who are
being responsible and not trying to
create the danger but what happens when
the danger is resolved and the person
who didn't create it is the one who's
still alive we don't lock them up in
prison
yeah it's and it's made uh I talk to
cops all the time I'm sure you have and
uh I still I have the same question I
respect the hell out of police officers
who still decide to do this job but
they're in a position right now I I
can't imagine doing this when you know
that the moment like you said Kim Potter
said I'm going to prison for this they
know that the moment a a criminal
decides to turn things physical
the police officers in a no-win
situation no matter what happens after
this they lose possibly everything
either they could die and if they don't
die if they commit the sin of not dying
then um they could lose their whole life
and go to prison and that's it's a it's
a total
we can't have a functioning civilization
when our law enforcement officers are
put in positions like this this is why
I'm
um almost entirely for abolishing the
police almost entirely because you know
part of me is like the police as law
enforcement makes sense we need in my
opinion good functioning law enforcement
I think uh many of our anarchists and
you know more and cap friends might be
like but uh I do I think if you have a
functioning legal system you basically
have which is what is supposed to be a
neutral Arbiter for conflict in in our
pop our you know dense environments that
makes sense I don't want two Neighbors
showing up and punching each other in
the face because they can't resolve a
dispute the cops get called come and
they say we're the ones who are going to
handle this that makes sense to me the
problem I have now is that with that you
know proposition you've mentioned the
police know okay I pulled this guy over
now he's giving me the business I'm out
I'm not going to stop him he's a violent
criminal minded on a gun charge for
armed robbery but I will not be Kim
Potter but what happens if you get
caught with a with a weapon what happens
if you live in New Jersey and like this
woman from Pennsylvania she drove across
the bridge go to Atlantic City didn't
realize she couldn't do this and had had
her legal gun with her in Pennsylvania
you're allowed to have weapons she drove
across the bridge gets pulled over and
the cop gleefully said ma'am you are
going to prison for four years and tried
to actually destroy her life the problem
I have now is you do have these police
like Kim Potter saying I'm going to
prison because she knows the political
power of black lives matter but you had
these you had cops in Minnesota traveled
south 20 miles to find a salon I believe
was a salon owner who refused A Cafe
owner she refused to close her business
during the covert restrictions and the
sheriff shows up with a smile on his
face and arrests her if these cops are
scared of black lives matter to the
point where they will let them get away
with riots and murder but but they're
not scared to arrest regular Americans
working-class citizens and conservatives
because these people never do anything
to resist we have a police force that
will disproportionately imprison good
honest Americans and at that point I'm
like you know what screw it abolish the
police
yeah I'm I'm I am sympathetic to the
idea of uh in these cities we're just
saying well okay give them give them
what they want if this is what they want
then let them you know you look at San
Francisco and all the Looting and
everything and I know there are a lot of
people on the right who are saying well
hey but that's that's this is what they
voted for so I got no problem with it
um and I understand that but then also I
can't
as as fundamentally a Law and Order and
Justice kind of guy I just hate the idea
of bad guys winning and so yeah I
understand that you live in San
Francisco you voted for this but at the
same time these are the bet these are
really bad guys who are doing the
Looting and the stealing and I just
don't I don't like the fact that they
win and um the bad guys you get rid of
the cops in the middle of the city and
it's going to be really bad for whatever
good people decide to stay there but the
bad guys will love it I mean but the
cops are acting like bad guys in many
instances a lot of times there's been a
lot of incidences where police officers
don't respond to crimes a lot of times
police officers just stand by and watch
crimes happen because of this kind of
chilling effect which you correctly
pointed out but when it comes to
political issues when it comes to going
after people for not doing the mask
mandate or not locking down when they're
supposed to they're on people like what
on white on rice and they go after them
and they and they go after them for the
fullest extent of the law and I think
there's an argument to make here that
the police forces have been politicized
to a point where only certain crimes
based on your ideology get punished
While others get ignored I would call
that behavior the behavior of bad guys
enforcing bad edicts and decrees I think
it's I think we got the I think there
are a lot of good cops a lot of good
cops quit I think when when it got too
hot you had a lot of cops saying I'm not
going to enforce these minutes and
lockdowns I'll resign a lot of who are
saying I will not enforce or be part of
vaccine mandates they resign and who's
left remaining the cops were like I
don't care tell me what to do and I'll
do it so let me ask you a question uh do
you believe that uh um like what's your
stance on the Second Amendment
fully in favor of it yeah do you think
it's like absolute
yeah yeah so uh I I've grown to be you
know fairly absolute on the Second
Amendment the right to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed it means
what it means it's verbatim that means
arms period it means during the
Revolutionary period there were
privateers privateers had
arsenals in their in these battleships
they had cannons they had grape shot
they could take on governments and they
would the privateers would get a letter
of Mark and then go and disrupt French
Supply supply lines these are private
citizens with canons and so the founding
fathers are like you can have all this
stuff all of it because a militia is a
militia just a bunch of guys with
muskets no no militia has a has weapons
artillery they have they have other
means today I think if you want to
change these laws if you want to ban
guns well you got a second amendment to
contend with so the issue now is in
places like Chicago in New York where
they don't allow you to even bear arms
in any capacity the cops in my opinion
who would arrest you simply because you
have a gun I don't care if you're gang
member I don't care if you're antifa I
don't care if you're a working class
plumber you have a right to keep in bear
arms period I don't care if your gauge
gross kreutz in Kenosha at a riot you
have a right to keep in bear arms you
don't have a right to use that weapon
illegally to cause damage to hurt people
but you can have a gun on your person
Second Amendment says it my opinion is
very much thanks to you know credit to
Michael malice who's going to be very
excited by the shout out because I'm
going to say it again the police and
this we're talking about this when we
were in Austin a police officer who
arrests a person who is constitutionally
keeping and bearing a gun and doing
nothing else is a bad guy
and the problem I have now is if he's
constitutionally doing so yeah right but
what about uh what about a
a felon uh uh I well so that's a good
argument felons have gone through due
process and have lost the right to keep
in bear arms that so I would argue that
um but I I've said this before we had
Alan West on the show and I said I think
you get out of prison you get your gun
back you get your vote back but many
people correctly pointed out that the
Constitution's rights can be rescinded
through due process meaning you can lose
your right to life liberty The Pursuit
of Happiness if you commit a crime we
lock you up and so you can lose your
right to keeping bear arms if you commit
a serious crime you go through due
process and then we say as a felon you
cannot keep in bear arms that I I agree
with I think there should probably be
some you know a time limit it's not just
indefinite for the rest of your life it
should be like and you're now a
registered felon for three years and
after that we allow you to go back to
having all your rights or whatever but
my issue is in Chicago
we have a lot of cases where 35 year old
dad he's got two kids Chicago's gang
territory he lives in the South Side and
he's like I need a gun to protect my
family but the state won't let him do it
so he gets a gun by driving to Indiana
buying it legally going home with it the
cops show up at his house you are going
to prison for the next you know six
years for illegal gun possession which I
don't believe should exist those cops in
my opinion are bad guys they're they're
there's good Working Class People who
just want to defend themselves and they
get targeted in this way or there's
there's two big stories you have uh in
Chicago an old a 60 year old woman from
Tennessee was uh uh I think for or from
Kentucky I'm not sure was going to
Chicago for a vacation and she brought
her you know snub nose you know 38 or
whatever and when she was at this year's
tower now Willis Tower they asked before
she went to the observation deck do you
have you know if you have any weapons
you can go through the metal detector
she said yeah I have my my concealed
carry with me and my permit and the cop
was like all right ma'am turn around
hands behind your back you're under
arrest and she did go to prison they
actually sent her to prison and they
said we don't care Illinois's laws are
not you know Kentucky's that to me is
evil oh great so I I I don't I don't
think you know at that time you have bad
cops you got a lot of bad cops willing
to absolutely enforce laws that are
unconstitutional the main issue I have
now is
how many resignations have we seen over
the past year or two there's a video of
a cop in Seattle being like you guys win
young protesters I quit I'm not I'm not
doing this anymore they've been
pressured out by the defund the police
the political pressures of the of the
Soros DA's and what's left is you got a
video from Seattle where a cop there's a
guy walking backwards with a baton or
with a bat or something antifa is
pointing things at him and threatening
him and he's walking backwards with his
hands up telling him to back off
cops are waiting at the intersection and
they yell at him get on the ground hands
on your head then they look over walk
over to antifung I'm so sorry about that
would you would you mind having your dog
step back I don't want anyone getting
hurt thank you so much ma'am and they
arrest the guy the guy who was
retreating from antifa is the guy who
got arrested that's the problem I have
right now if cops are are scared of
black lives matter and antifa that means
it's going to be Independence
conservatives Libertarians who are going
to be shuffled into prisons and they're
going to be releasing antifa or refusing
to prosecute yeah I think uh first of
all the whole following order's excuse
is never that that never washes and we
know that historically and that goes for
cops too and I would agree that uh you
know
finding someone who's made some base
basically that's like a paperwork
mistake where someone held the gun
legally and they crossed state lines and
then you just decide okay I'm gonna ruin
your life I'm just just because I can't
I'm going to ruin your whole life uh
yeah that that is that is definitely
evil and I do agree also that there's a
problem when we are actively pushing the
good ones out through all the things
that you point out uh but I still think
that you look at the cops
who are who are still on the force
um there are still plenty of good ones
left and I've like I said I've talked to
them myself and the reasons that they
give why they're still there one reason
is actually I believe in this job and I
care about it
um another reason is the real simple one
with this is what I've done my whole
life this is how I feed my family and
this is how I support my family and I'm
I'm always I'm always sympathetic to
that because I have four kids myself I
haven't been in a position where I've
had to think about am I just going to
leave all this behind him and my and I
won't have a way to feed my kids I
haven't had to think about that but um
when you really have to think about it
it's it's just I can certainly
understand someone deciding I'm staying
in this because uh it's this is my
livelihood I do agree I do agree and I
don't think
um I think many of the cops that are
enforcing this stuff are Mindless and
that they don't know they don't care but
I think that means the good cops that
remain and those who say look I know
that's bad but I have to support my
family
they need to start enacting police
nullification like jury nullification
the officers should refuse to enforce
laws and many are that are
unconstitutional or unjust so we have
Sanctuary counties Sanctuary States for
gun rights where the police have
straight up said we are not going to
arrest anybody for for guns because they
have a right to keep and bear them now I
think it's reasonable if I've got some
kind of long gun or a handgun on my
person I think if a cop comes up to me
and says you know we want to check out
the weapon to make sure you know it's
safe and we want to talk to you about it
within reason I'm I think that's
acceptable but I also think that if
you're if I was in an area
where say you're you the open carry is
not allowed or a person was let's say a
person I believe the police should
probably be like hey we want to talk to
you about the weapon we want you to know
that the statute here is that you can't
have the weapon out in public but we're
not going to enforce that because it's
unconstitutional we want to make sure
you're not committing any crimes we want
to make sure everything's safe you're
good have a nice day sir I think the
police should be doing that but and they
already do they do it in favor of BLM
they do it in favor of antifa and we
have to call it out for what they're
doing and that line I have to disagree
with you a little bit here Matt that
line I'm just doing my job I'm just
doing this just for my kids just for my
family this is this is what led to the
worst human atrocities all throughout
recorded human history I'm not just
talking about Germany I think that's
overplayed overused but when we look at
you know for for Soviet Russia as an
example with with the KGB even if we
look at what's happening right now in
Australia people are being hauled off
into camps because they were around
people that tested positive for covid
and police officers are literally
ruining people's lives telling them that
they can't go to the supermarket denying
them basic human rights to food and
water all because they didn't comply
with the whims of the state and the
state is only willing to pull it off
because officers saying well I'm just
doing my job I just have to feed my
family I think it's dangerous and it I
think that needs to be called out yeah
just to clarify that point uh yeah I
don't accept that excuse for police
officers who are doing something evil
like we talked about that that's not
that's I agree with you there that that
is that goes into the I'm following
orders I'm feeding my family if you're
doing something evil you're doing
something evil there's no excuse for it
I'm talking about in general we look
across the country the police officers
who in spite of all of this are still on
the force why are they there I think uh
the good ones anyway I think that's when
you get into two reasons one is I really
believe in this and I want to do it and
the other is I'm feeding my family
um and so it's not just that the only
cops Who Remain across the board are you
know the bad ones I don't think that's
true let's talk about Australia the
first thing I want to do is uh highlight
we have this article here NT records no
new cases of covid-19 overnight
following nine binjari cases this is
Australian news desperately trying to
bury the lead about the military
transporting the indigenous to covet
camps I want to show you this from
breaking 9-1-1 oh I'm sorry that's the
that's the wrong one where is it it's
right here here we go Talia sarf
breaking 9 news has been told several
people have absconded the Howard Springs
quarantine facility early this morning
the police investigation is right now
underway Talia is a reporter I believe
she is the senior reporter for 9 News
Darwin
uh can anybody Define absconded for me
well I I believe that means they up and
left
it sounds like a word I made up yeah it
does uh yes it means they up and left
yes and the police are investigating oh
what why that's crazy I thought it was
voluntary to be at the the quarantine
facility yeah I thought they were having
fun taking Instagram selfies of those
house let me show you this this is from
abc.net.aus Australian Broadcast News
and they have the WHERE let me see where
where's the story I'm always struggling
to find the uh the part in here where
they talk about the 30 here we go
he said this is Gunner this is the
Minister of the the Northeast
territories he said the authorities had
identified 38 close contacts in benjari
a number he said would likely rise who
were transported to Howard Springs on
Sunday
uh Mr Garner said cases in binjai were
very concerning but not surprising yada
yada he went on to thank he thanked the
the military the ADF for for signing I
think they sent out 20 individuals to
help transport these people
he's in
urging them all to get vaccinated and
let me see if this is in the article as
well authorities have identified okay so
that's not it there is there's another
article I remember pulled up where they
say
in the speech he gave he said that
benjari will be entering hard lockdown
that means the citizens no longer have
the five reasons to leave their house
which is exercise food visiting your one
contact or whatever whatever the five
reasons are quite literally this man has
said
if you are in this this territory you
cannot leave your house to eat
then they've started transporting close
contacts and suspected cases to the
quarantine facilities now I'm reasonably
assured by Claire Lehman of quilette
that uh this is
um impoverished communities who need
desperate help and are bringing brought
to uh to hospitals and I'm a blowhard
who has no idea what he's talking about
Jesse single the reporter says Tim pool
is pushing dangerous conspiracies or
some other garbage nonsense in reality
it's Jesse who hasn't done a single
Google search of this before
regurgitating garbage nonsense what I
have said is quite simply if you tell
indigenous people they can't leave their
homes to eat and then say but by all
means get in the military vehicle or
whatever vehicle being driven by the ADF
to go to the quarantine facility it's
not voluntary and if it was we wouldn't
be see we wouldn't see people absconding
and if the people did abscond from the
facility you wouldn't see police putting
up press releases saying they've started
an investigation to search for those who
scaled the offense and escaped yeah they
had a national Manhunt for a man that
sneezed in an elevator in Australia this
this was also the same guy I believe his
name was Gunner who came out and
publicly said that if you took the vax
but you don't like the mandates that
you're an anti-vaxxer because you're
providing Aid support and comfort to
anti-vaxxers that's his definition of an
anti-vaxxer now is aiding and supporting
anyone who doesn't like what the
government is doing on their whims and
they literally took this was a couple
days ago 38 indigenous people had the
military haul them off into these
quarantine camps because they had close
contact with someone who allegedly
tested positive so there's also
indigenous people coming out and making
videos alleging that they are being
kidnapped that they're also having
forced to be medicated so again it's
it's still untrue if any of these
allegations are true or not but these
are some of the allegations against the
state of Australia that is becoming more
orwellian and more dangerous by the day
and I wouldn't be so surprised if these
accusations were true what is is it the
uh the lowest level of hell is that how
it works yeah I'm not sure which one
Israel are you familiar with Dante's
Inferno yeah the lowest level is that we
would say properly there's there's that
saying that the lowest level is is
reserved for for um Traders disloyal I
think is that I don't know but I'm
reminded of that line from um that great
line from Pirates of the Caribbean where
he says the inner circle of hell yeah
yeah I think I think what Jack Sparrow
says is the lowest level of hell is
reserved for betrayers and mutineers and
he says that to the people who betrayed
him and Community or whatever and that's
why I think it's really important to um
bring this up in the context of Claire
Lehman of quelette are you familiar with
with Colette yeah so I mean this was
very much an intellectual dark web
publication a few years ago challenging
wokeness and you know the Orthodoxy of
the of the cathedral and the state and
now
Claire Lehman has become an overt State
propagandist literally posting pictures
of bikini-clad women enjoying their stay
at the forced quarantine facility where
we are now getting indigenous people
transported to and the police now
putting up press releases to try and
find those who've absconded from them
yeah uh can I read the definition of
abscondual oh yeah I looked it up okay
so absconding is leading Hurley and
Secret
of or arrest for unlawful actions such
as theft
so they're definitely concerned about so
it's by force this is 100 by four no one
is is going here voluntarily to be
detained by force and you can't yeah and
they're literally admitting it in the
words they use there was a woman who who
escaped and they went on a hunt to try
and find her a man to escape now we have
this story The thing about Claire is
that she's uh look I made a tweet where
I referred to these camps as
concentration camps I was being
hyperbolic it's Twitter someone said
here's a here's a picture of their
quarantine facilities and then I put
Asterix concentration camp she took that
and went off and called me you know
insulted me and said that I was
exaggerating and my point was look we've
already seen videos there's a video I
don't know if you've seen it Matt where
a guy is at his house and the police
pull-up and the media is there waiting
and they interview him as he's being
brought out and arrested by the cops
arrested quote unquote and he's like I
don't know what's going on they're
telling me I've tested positive for
covid and I guess I'm gonna go in this
van and go with them and they announced
that he will be indefinitely quarantined
that's literally what they said in the
Press reports I'm like I don't know
where they brought him but this video
exists my point was if they built camps
to House people they say are a danger or
undesirable how long until they are
concentration camps where they go to a
community and say you are being
transported this facility how long until
there's a protest against the lockdowns
and they say oh the anti-lockdown
protest was a super spreader event gotta
round up all those protesters and send
them to quarantine because they could be
infected and I was told by a reporter
for ABC I was told by Claire Lehman that
I was a conspiracy theorist I was told
that these were just international
arrival Bungalows and now more and more
we're learning they are forcefully
denying people food forcefully
relocating with military assistance and
people are trying to escape these
facilities I don't care if the photos
look lovely and they've posted great
little photos of the beds and little
welcome packs and sandwiches and smiling
hot babes in bikinis you want to put out
propaganda by all means do it but when
you put out reports about people trying
to escape this place yeah I'm going to
call it a concert that was the cop's own
words I think Escape right didn't you
just say we're trying to prevent I'm
going to use that when I leave here
Matt you had something to say yeah I
think people when you use words like
concentration camp and I think you can
make an argument for for that for that
phrase in a kind of a literal sense it's
a it's a camp where there's a
concentration of of people there but and
then we get into the semantics oh you
can't say that it's we're calling it a
rival Bungalow I think one thing is that
people there's a lot there are a lot of
people who who they just cannot wrap
their heads around the idea that things
could really get that bad or be that bad
you know the idea that the government
would put people into camps at all it's
like we don't you know that's in the
past that's not a thing that happens
anymore we we've moved past that as a
world it's just it's just not possible
they don't want to accept the reality or
the possibility that um that that
something that could even happen I think
that's a lot of what that is the Nazis
didn't come out one day and say
everybody we're going to execute you in
death camps get in the trucks that's not
how I'm down there there's horrifyingly
photos of people smiling getting in
these vehicles getting on these trains
people were posting them on Twitter yeah
and they used the excuse of a sickness
to get a lot of people away from their
communities to go on their trains
um and one of my favorite responses to
uh that lady that you just mentioned
that's uh Claire Claire lemon yeah one
of my favorite responses to her tweet
was a picture of a Japanese internment
camp and it was the Japanese people
playing
um softball look these Japanese people
really enjoyed the their internment
camps here in the United States as well
they were playing sports and and that's
akin to again compare it's not fair to
really compare a lot of World War II
stuff but when we're going into a place
where the government is saying that
you're an anti-vaxxer because you're
aiding and supporting people's uh
ideology and not believing in the
government he said when you oppose the
Mandate yes you are anti-vaccine yes
exactly you're an anti-vaxxer that's
very dangerous language the state is
empowering themselves with powers that
they shouldn't have god-like authority
over individuals sovereignty over
individual bodily autonomy and when that
happens historically bad things happen
we should just be able to say that if
we're in a position where the government
is
forcibly containing people against their
will who have not committed a crime or
even been accused of a crime then that
leads to very bad places and people get
upset about Holocaust comparisons and
everything and sometimes they get calls
like well that's anti-semitic which of
course is absurd because the point of
the cop of the comparison is that this
is a really bad thing the other point of
the comparison is that we don't want it
to get like we've seen in history how
bad it can get when you allow the
government this kind of leeway we don't
want it to get there so let's let's pay
attention now but also the response to
my you know tweets was that people were
saying well is there evidence they're
taking these people by forced him is
there evidence that these indigenous
people were forced by the military to go
and I'm like why is that even a question
that is that is a propaganda
manipulation in an attempt to try and
make it seem like people are happily
going into forced lockdown where they're
not allowed to leave and they're not
even sick they're just suspected of
being sick that's another crazy element
of here that we need to talk about as
well I'll put it this way if you are
told you can't leave your home you're
told that you're not allowed to go
outside for food and then we do have a
van waiting outside to take you to a
quarantine facility where you will not
be allowed to leave but we do have food
yeah they're forcing you like if you
lock someone in their house and starve
them and say you can only come out when
you agree to go to the camp where you'll
never be allowed to leave well for two
weeks or however long they hold you
right then you are forcing them yeah so
it's interesting that you mentioned
concentration camps I was just reading
about Hannah Arendt and she was one of
the Jews who managed to escape
um the Nazis she talked about how Hope
was very much one of the Jews worst
enemies during the Holocaust because
people would get on the trains
voluntarily which is real freaking
interesting that Claire mentions that
people are voluntarily doing this
she never said voluntary no no what
happened was she said she admitted she
agreed that these people are being
relocated and she said it was because
they're from poor communities that don't
have access to hospitals other
Australians commented what do you mean
it was it called the Catherine Hospital
or whatever is right there the immediate
sponsor the propaganda says oh it's not
good enough it's not good enough it's
barely a hospital I thought there was no
hospital I thought you said it wouldn't
happen now it is happening and you're
saying it's a good thing then of course
when there was a massive backlash
because no in no context is as good the
media in Australia and the government
officials started saying that me and a
few other people were conspiracy
theorists and I am proud to say that in
one of her tweets she referred to
imagine Nawaz and I as conspiracy
theorists putting up false information
and I'm honored yeah to be named
alongside imagine it was he's a he's a
great thinker he's a brilliant guy he's
a good dude and um wow you know I I
thank you yeah great compliment it's
amazing and it turns out
um they can lie all they want but all
I'm doing is literally quoting their
official news sources yeah the guardian
and their own police releases I'm just
critical of what they're doing and they
don't like it
hmm I just I just saw a chat that said
Auschwitz had a
what wouldn't you have an opera house
and a swimming pool I I I look look
maybe it didn't what people they the
history is condensed when people look at
it so our our last understanding of what
happened with the concentration camps is
how horrifying it was and we all know
what what they did right but you're not
going to get millions of people to load
themselves into train cards by telling
them what your end plan is exactly and
not only that I was reading about this
and the craziest thing was that there
were a lot of Jewish people in Germany
who didn't believe it when when the when
the op-eds were coming out saying the
Nazis wanted to do this stuff we're
planning on doing it they're like eh
that'll never happen this is exactly
what we're seeing now with Australia you
know what happened when the American
troops came in and the French and the
British came in and liberated those
camps you know what they did to those
German people that pretended like they
didn't know it was going on they put
them into forced labor and made them
clean the camps interesting don't act
like that's not going on yeah a lot of
the you know concentration camps were
deemed also work camps that's where uh
my family was sent into my uh great
great grandmother uh was of course sent
into one of these camps because they
didn't like what was going on they
wouldn't sign their polish citizenship
over to a German citizenship they
resisted uh the Stasi beat up my
great-grandfather killed him they sent
my great grandmother to a work camp and
they sent my grandmother who's still
alive into one of the work camps as well
and of course they didn't tell them like
hey this is where things are you know
they didn't tell them like hey this is
where their their plan obviously they
always said what people wanted to hear
or needed to hear in order to comply and
go along and then uh you know the story
I'm told by my grandmother is once my
great-grandmother resisted and was
trying to organize something at one of
the labor camps they sent her to a
different camp and that was one of the
concentration camps located near dusk
Poland and that's where she went missing
while my grandmother stayed at that work
camp and then was there ever since of
course then Russians came in and then
the Soviets came in and then took over
Poland and then rolled in their own
decree and she even says that what the
Soviets did was even in many instances
even worse than what the Germans did uh
to the Polish people the original
definition of concentration camp was a
camp where a group of people are
concentrated for you know variety of
reasons but that was
1800s you know with World War II
concentration camp came to take a very
serious meaning which typically refers
to camps where people are brought to
eventually die right so of course I'll
be the first to say when I said Asterix
concentration camp I am of course being
hyperbolic to to make a point right
don't let governments build camps
pick people up and force them to go
there let's not go there bad things
happen whenever that happens I think it
would also be helpful maybe just as a as
a collective as a culture if we
one of the problems we go to the
Holocaust analogy all the time because
it's one thing that we know that
everybody will will it's one of the few
historical facts that we know that
everyone that everyone knows but uh but
maybe we expand our historical analogies
because there are many examples in fact
you don't go that far geographically or
in terms of timeline to find I think
maybe even better comparisons what we're
going through right now in Stalin's
Soviet Union they're they're they're you
know some some parallels there as well
so part part of the problem is that we
always go to the to the to the Holocaust
and that's because of the kind of like
in our culture the historical illiteracy
that we can't talk about any other
historical event and be sure that
everyone's going to know what even what
we're referring to right right everybody
basically knows what went down in World
War II and so it's it's an easy
reference to make it so powerful
pronounced and and it was it's like the
epitome of evil in a lot of people's
minds even though the holiday more what
Stalin was doing was massively evil
what are the Communist skill 100 million
people I mean that that was it that is
to this day a dangerous ideology and
when you look at what's going on today
it's kind of scary that I mean these
people still exist they're gaining power
they're pushing their ideas through
institutions
and it's worrying what that would mean
for the rest of us if we don't stand up
speak out now and and you know challenge
the these institutions and try and get
jobs there and there's so much that
needs to be done to try and push back on
this stuff yeah my grandmother who
literally saw her father killed by the
Stasi said that the Soviets were way
worse than the Germans uh comparatively
to what they did to the Polish people
there's also a lot of Polish
intellectuals a lot of professors a lot
of Scholars that were literally taken
away in the middle of the night by the
Soviets and then executed in the middle
of woods no one really likes to talk
about that as well but there was a large
number of executions a lot of people
sent to labor camps which of course
eventually led to them dying in these
labor camps because of the conditions
there and truly you know you know
Germany is is one aspect of it but
there's a whole other aspect that it
absolutely is being significantly
underplayed and that of course is what
communism has done to the world the
gulag archipelago is a boy that should
be a sign it should be a signed reading
in public school and of course it isn't
but that's something that at least the
first two volumes and it's kind of it
seems like a daunting task to read but
it actually it reads it you could read
through it pretty quickly
um given what it is and and that of
course Soldier Nissan and the the first
I think it's the first chapter the first
volume
uh kind of plays in a lot of what we're
talking about here is because he talks
about how you know the secret police
would show up and they would just you
know they would they'd show up one day
and they'd just arrest you and they can
send you off to a labor camp it'll be
gone for 10 15 years or you'll never
come back maybe and everyone knows that
this is going on and yet they everyone
just still convinces themselves that it
won't happen to them it can't be that
real and so he talks about how somehow
even though like you see your this
happens to your neighbor it happens to
your your cousin your aunt the person
across the street and yet when they come
for for you you're still shocked and in
a panic and and surprised this is
happening uh because it's something
psychologically where we just can't
believe that it'll happen to us I think
that when they finally do come for you
it's under the guise of it's just come
with us it's it's for your safety it's
for your safety and people just go okay
and they grab their bag and they
peacefully go along with them and then
they hope it'll work out yep yeah
because people just they keep saying it
can never happen here and look at so
much that has happened here it's
literally happening right now all around
us the lockdowns the restrictions the
mandates and people are still saying
it's fine it's normal it can't happen
here the illegal mandates that were
again
shirked by the courts I hear living in
good times and living in peace is an
exception to the rule the role of
history is conflict it's fighting it's
demicide I mean my uncle not so long ago
kidnapped by the Soviets tortured uh by
of course the government there for not
having its paperwork at a random paper
please checkpoint uh in Poland people
need to understand Luke you were born in
the Soviet well you were born in a
Soviet satellite like the Soviet Union
existed and you were born in a country
that was experiencing this this is
within our lifetimes and stuff was going
down and it could happen again I mean a
lot of people who live through it are
saying the same exact thing is happening
repeating people are making a lot of
references to the cultural revolution in
China people are making a lot of
references to what happened in Soviet
Russia and I think there are some very
scary
um lessons to learn there that I do
believe in a smaller instance are
repeating and could fully roll downhill
to towards even worser versions of what
we saw in China and the Soviet Union
because of the technocratic angle that
is a full on track trace and database
society that sees everything imagine if
Stalin if Mao Zedong if Hitler had the
power of total information control total
dominance and was able to control what
people thought that power right there is
absolutely frightening I just want to
stress that point you know talking about
you know Luke being born in Poland when
uh so the wall was still yeah the wall
was still there
what we're experiencing now is kind of
like a recess
it's all gonna it all comes back like
Luke mentioned I mean it was it was
throughout the the 20th century you had
World War II and then you had the
Soviets it was a hundred years of
authoritarianism and just horrifying
horrifying things and we have this
period now where it's kind of been okay
but now it's bubbling back up to get bad
again so if we don't you know fight for
our values and stand up and say no and
protect yourself from cult worship uh
obsession with Trump Biden and fouchy
anybody really but that's a lot of these
communist regimes came came to power
totalitarian like Hitler Mao Stalin they
were their Cult of Personality in a lot
of ways we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel and uh
don't forget to go to timcast.com to
become a member for that members only
segment which will be coming up around
11 or so p.m but now we're going to read
your comments see what you got to say
one person said don't forget about the
uyghur Muslims still happening today
this kind of stuff still happens I need
proof because people hit me on Twitter
and they're like it's false news that's
propaganda Western propaganda don't
believe it
I don't buy it dude look it's you you
look at what China has done what they do
and what they're doing and I'm just like
less inclined to believe with you
correlation I can't I can't it's not
true and and the United States has
really really awful things too I'm not
here to play games about America it's
not about America I just want proof that
these camps are real there's videos
there's I've seen videos
on trains but no and that's and that's
true it's like context right right it's
hard to know exactly what the context is
but I'll put it this way it's hard to
know for sure but if they're not going
to let people into these investigations
and they're going to borrow us from say
woo and all that stuff and I'm just
gonna err on the side of I don't believe
you yeah I'm not going to deny that all
right we got some super chats here the
first one I can't read your name sorry
because we have that uh pinned merch up
which blocks your name unfortunately but
uh check out that step on snack and find
out shirt in that chat sweet baby gang
for Life yes what is it
I can't talk about it I can't explain it
is it related to Mark Zuckerberg sweet
baby back that's not really it's not
related to anything okay the sweet baby
gang is what it is it is what it is
that's all all right um oh this one
seems important I guess Derby wormy says
Matt what will it take to have you and
the rest of the daily wire play Halo
infinite
what is Halo infinite that's a good
story I didn't know if that was like a
thing for you guys if someone was asking
that I have I've started playing a
couple of video games on like YouTube
and doing the video game reaction I
don't play any video games at all so
that's why it's a thing but yeah
I don't know if the daily wire had like
a Halo infinite thing they were doing
but I I would do it yeah oh there you go
I'll do it because that's the way the
word works over there they just tell me
that oh we're doing this this thing and
I show up and then we're recording and I
just do it so that's great do you play
the banjo
uh I I have a banjo and um the truth is
that I've I've never I've never played
it at all I don't know how to play it at
all oh okay but I've had it in my studio
my wife got me a bit I think it was like
maybe a year after we got married and uh
she went out and got me a banjo because
I've been talking a lot of game but I
wanted to learn it and then she got it
and uh and she did and she got it and uh
informed me then she got me like a
little like a little booklet to learn
how to do it and then it just kind of
sat there for years in the corner of the
room looking at me judging me because I
never learned it and uh then I put it in
my studio and that's it I'm a fraud I
guess
all right let's see Katherine McGrath
says you've said once someone eats
someone they're accountable for Life
what about people who are forced into it
by circumstance so the context here is
we were having a discussion about Reza
Azlan he's the CNN guy who ate human
brain and I said he's a cannibal
and we had a discussion about are you
defined by the worst thing you've ever
done and I'm like a cannibal is someone
who eats human right he ate human and
then the response actually gets yeah but
only one time and I'm like why do we
tolerate that like we're not going to
call you a cannibal whereas if you kill
someone You're a murderer yeah and then
we're not going to be like well it was a
long time ago it's not a murderer
anymore
so he's an ex-murder now former murderer
I don't know you what so okay so it's a
little bit like being an alcoholic they
say an AAA that once you're an alcoholic
you're an alcoholic for life you never
change like it's something you have to
be constantly Vigilant about and I think
one of the problems that these people
have with the Reza Aslan thing is that
he did in fact just do it once whatever
but they need to understand that they're
making like a bit of an equivocation by
saying that it has to be a pattern it
doesn't have to be a pattern if you're
if you murder someone just one person
you're a murderer not a mass murderer
that doesn't change doesn't really
matter what you do so it's a little I
feel like they're making a little bit
and what if you're forced into it I
still think yeah I still think it
applies depending on the question forced
into it like you're stranded on an
island well Reza Aslan apparently when
he was sitting down with these religious
types
if he didn't eat the brain he could have
been attacked by them so the argument a
lot of people have is like he did this
interview and then they told him eat it
now and his perception was like these
people will chase beat and potentially
kill us unless I do as I'm told
yeah I think for that you're out of luck
he's accountable for life if we were
talking about a situation where people
are stranded or something and then
you're starving and someone's already
dead and then you know those kinds of
extreme situations I think
maybe I wouldn't Define them by that for
the rest of their life I wouldn't call a
soldier a murderer I wouldn't call Kim
Potter a murderer I think that's an
extreme statement for someone who's like
in a life or death situation and forced
to make a move they didn't want to make
you know as far as Aslan he chose to
enter that situation with these cannibal
with these cannibals he knew who knew
were cannibals he knew who were
consuming human flesh at the time who
handed him human flesh and he could have
run right he did it for clout like the
issue with uh you know with with uh
Rittenhouse he ran um so I wouldn't call
him a murderer he ran away he tried to
avoid this Kim Potter was trying to
arrest a guy in a felony weapons charger
dove into his vehicle and she
accidentally shot him not a murderer you
know this guy
I don't know man you know I think I
think it's an interesting point how many
grains of sand make a heap so it's a
hard it's a hard question sometimes hard
to find Turkey
falconizer says Tim you need to get JP
Sears on I saw him live and during q a I
asked him when he's going on your show
and he said he'd love to if he was
invited he wasn't he was invited and
part of the problem if you're seeing him
in a live show it's because he's really
busy so part of the problem is he's too
darn busy do a live show out in the east
coast and then stop by yeah because we
think you're fantastic or we could do a
show together and work that out and or
we could book him for a show uh I think
that would be I love his videos I think
they're they're very very very uh
satirical I mean and extremely hilarious
and luckily YouTube hasn't figured out
how to censor satire yet but when they
do he's gone we've got we've got for
damastan we don't need to do anything to
have an event there yeah we can just
literally be like 100 tickets okay yeah
and have him perform and then we'll get
a PA system and we'll get you know some
chairs let's book them
outdoor you're talking yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh maybe it's too cold yeah
maybe it's warm for sure we set up fire
pits we'll do it we'll do it we'll give
ourselves two weeks so it'll be in the
50s it'll be in the 40s or 50s people
can wear hoodies they'll be fine fire
pits we should do an arena with JP no
we'll do it we'll do a big fire we'll do
a bonfire it's a big open field awesome
dude yeah well that could be like our
opening thing maybe Ryan long want to
come
along and then we'll just hang out in a
big open field and you know we'll do it
uh on a Saturday for the whole day just
like a hangout yeah yeah we'll bring
dirt bikes and we'll ride around and
next week
next weekend like not this coming
weekend but the weekend after yeah all
right let's see if we can pull off a
miracle JP get in contact with us follow
us on Twitter and then we'll we'll set
it up
all right Ricky M says Jeffrey tuben's
incident needs to be referred to
referred to as tubing it for example
where is Jeff out didn't you hear the
boss fired him he was caught tubing it
on last week's Zoom meeting
that's good I honestly his name is tuben
you know what I mean like that's Lubin
tuben it's like you could say tubing it
as a reference to you know male
self-gratification it's a simulation
it's almost as good as as Weiner yeah
yeah I know right he's in that ballpark
we you know what I love um
simulation Theory stuff certainly this
is a miracle yes this is this is this is
evidence of a higher power having you
know created all right let's see sense
of humor for sure Aaron Miller says Tim
you mentioned Marvel Matt looks like
Netflix Daredevil also rezel Aslan
didn't lose it he became super CNN and
couldn't handle the madness
yeah you you do kind of look like the
guy who played Daredevil you know what's
his name I don't know I don't know what
is his name
I have no idea sorry I'm gonna take that
as a compliment yeah yeah okay Superhero
he's an actor yeah
all right
Jacob Howard says Tim you will not have
my respect until you have Shapiro cliff
and Walsh and Knowles in your podcast at
the same time in a van by the way Matt
just bought your book for my little
brothers uh SBG all day yeah
so what is it sweet baby gang sweet baby
Gangnam sweet baby gang so um actually I
think in January we're going to be
hanging out at the daily wire
headquarters you are yeah yeah we were
they were trying to get us to come out
um we went to Austin and they were they
were trying to get us the week before
with Austin so we'd bring our mobile
Studio then we'd do the show from the RV
with the daily like many people from the
daily wire and um in Austin we did the
Super Show the Austin show with Joe
Rogan Alex Jones Blair White Michael
malice Drew Hernandez Lou me and
everybody else and it was massive
if we could figure out a way to have you
know you Clavin Knowles band Candace all
like popping in and just having this
Rowdy obnoxious thing we got two million
you know views already not to mention
the live version got 600k and then the
podcast is at 200 or something I'm into
it and I'll say that we can do it I'm
also perfect I'm signing all the money
oh yeah
yeah I mean we had nine people
on like just and it was a cacophony of
craziness it was wild but it was fun it
was fun and you know and and you know
Joe popped in for about an hour we were
fortunate we're grateful for him to be
there and yeah I like how you guys ran
out those big event spaces yeah we just
we did it at the Ryman in Nashville that
was that'd be cool to rent that out
while we're down there well that was
actually one of the plans we had was if
we could do a Friday Night Live Tim cast
IRL in the venue and set up a studio
table and get everything so there's like
a live audience watching that'd be
that'd be great
yeah super fun
all right let's read some more here
okay Doug Kaplan says Matt Walsh awesome
guest and I think you two should
infuriate CNN get on camera in Disguise
and show facts on CNN lie off their own
camera live CNN confession live
all right that's a strategy I don't know
that would work people are saying LeBron
has covet is that true yeah I'm hearing
a lot of reports on that on social media
I don't know if has it has been
confirmed he is double vaccinated but as
we know that hasn't stopped a lot uh is
that true that did bongino I didn't find
that okay so someone was lying I'm not
sure just not sure someone was yanking
out a chain impossible did you hear that
bongino got breakthrough coven
I didn't hear that no I didn't hear
about it I didn't hear about LeBron
either yeah people must be yanking our
chain in these super chats you can't
believe what you read on the internet
you know the thing is I used to actually
be I'm embarrassed now I used to be a
big LeBron fan back in the day and uh
yeah I know that's sorry that's the
Grimace I know yeah
um but he just
the last few years maybe I didn't see it
before it's possibly the case but the
guys I honestly told us government he
didn't seem to be like that before yeah
something's changed the Washington Post
is reporting Laker Star LeBron James out
indefinitely due to NBA covid-19 health
and safety protocols so maybe he's an
anti-vaxxer if the CIA says it it must
be true oh yeah just a man says you're
right Tim we were founded on
judeo-christian values and guess what we
atheists had to change about those
values Tim things like slavery okay uh
that's wrong it wasn't atheists he's
trying to credit atheists with
abolishing slavery no that's not true we
just talked about how people are
historically illiterate there we go good
example uh in the 1800s this country was
100 Christian I mean literally not 100
but you get my point like yeah atheism
didn't start to rise until probably what
like 70s into the 80s and 90s and even
then it was probably very few people
yeah the Abolitionist Movement was 100 a
Christian Movement but through and
through it wasn't yourself like they
happen to be Christian this was it was
their Christian principles had led them
to this so and I'm pretty sure to this
day I think what the country is like
what percentage of America is Christian
it's it's like 70 it's it's declining
but it's still 70 years and I think in
the 90s it was 80 or 90 you know really
high and so it's only a recent
phenomenon where atheists are gaining
political prominence I mean didn't we
just have like uh some of our first
atheist politicians in the past like 10
or 20 years I don't know know so if you
want to go back to the 1800s and claim
it was atheists who are doing these
things it's not true I got no disrespect
for atheists none at all um I am I am uh
I believe in God I don't follow any
theistic religions or anything like that
but I think it's like you said
historically illiterate to claim that 90
years of the Declaration of Independence
was signed this country had a lot a
strong atheist movement trying to
abolish slavery it's a it's a real it's
actually a real problem for atheists and
I'd be curious to I've got to hear an
atheist really sort through this but
because one of the reasons why the
Abolitionist Movement was was definitely
Christian is that it's it based on this
idea that we're all equal you know
created equal in the eyes of God that we
all have inherent human dignity human
rights
um the the doctrine of Human Rights is a
Doctrine it's a religious doctrine that
stems from this idea that we have human
Souls that we're you know that we have
this kind of Eternal significance if you
take that out of it and you're left with
uh Darwinism what what what do human
rights even mean you get wokism you get
right makes right you get the the the
the uh it was a um
um
what was it uh Graber um what was the
name of the anarchists
um the philanthropy uh Anarchist
Anthropologist was it David Graber I
think his name was he said um you know
uh rest in peace he passed a couple
years ago I believe but he said on
Twitter that the left is embracing
fascistic um tenets you know the idea
that there's no truth but power that
might makes right this is what wokeism
is when they've lost a moral framework
they just say if there is no moral
framework then why follow any rules why
it's it's really fascinating to be
completely honest because For the
Longest Time growing up there was the
religious argument of you know without
faith and religion then where do your
morals come from and a lot of you know
Bill Maher would be like that's a scary
prospect that the only reason you're not
killing people is because you you have
this religion and I'm like yeah honestly
I kind of understand that because you
can see people who might not be
religious who might be atheist but their
values still came from parents who held
these Traditional Values things like I
mean you know what man
too many people today haven't read the
story the story of Sodom and Gomorrah
right is there you know the actual name
of the uh the the story I don't know I
don't know much about the Bible well
yeah you had it's ungroup yeah so so you
basically you had um do you know what do
you know the name of the guy who was
lot yeah there you go see I don't I
don't know I don't it's been a long time
since I read this but I read it because
I was I was trying to understand the
fifth and sixth amendment I was trying
to understand the Constitution the Bill
of Rights the inalienable rights and it
was it was it was pulling out of thread
it was like here the founding fathers
had these discussions about why these
rights need to be included
and they reference God and they
reference religion in the Bible and they
reference blackstone's formulation and I
started reading about it and then sure
enough you discovered that the story is
quite literally you know God was like
this is a wicked you know these Wicked
cities will be destroyed and a lot is
like but what if there's righteous
people there and ultimately says if
there's but one righteous person I won't
do it and the idea from that is you
can't condemn the innocent because
you're mad at the guilty right the
fascinating thing is
if you look if you read about the
philosophy of innocent until proven
guilty dictators and tyrants tend to
hold the inverted view I think Otto von
Bismarck was his name he said it is
better that 10 innocent people suffer
than one guilty person Escape yeah yikes
that that that is a nation that will
imprison overwhelmingly innocent people
and cause Mass suffering on Grand scales
that's evil
that's pure evil 100 yeah that's the
definition of Eagle well I think that's
what we're getting with these people who
have no moral Frameworks at all it
doesn't have to be you don't have to be
religious or anything like that you have
to recognize people's rights
all right Eamon says Matt how's living
in Loudoun County
uh it was it was great you know uh I
felt connected with my true Virginia
Roots but we did we did ultimately
decide to move back to to relocate back
to Tennessee how long did you uh live in
London
um uh one and a half days
My Wife and Kids never made the move and
so that was a little bit of a that was a
little bit I didn't consult my wife
before buying you know before ranting a
she never agreed to live in someone's
basement in Loudoun County and so that's
fair that was it was a little bit of a
thing and so Loudoun County is about 30
seconds from here yeah we noticed we
went over through it yeah yeah so you
hopped down the road of course the the
schools are more like one hour yeah I
thought it was further I don't think I
drove out there it was like 20 minutes
yeah it's not that far a lot of it's not
that big maybe I got stuck in traffic I
don't know yeah yeah no we we go down
there uh to where those schools are you
know relatively often okay maybe it's a
half an hour yeah it's always maybe
maybe whatever look I I know we're close
to Loudoun County this I used to live
here so that's right that's right that's
right of course yes uh he was gonna say
that was one Epic mic drop speech back
in September thanks for fighting the
fight let's go Brandon that was a good
speech Matt yeah uh yeah well at the
Loudoun County thing it was it was so
ridiculous because you know they they
give you they give you 60 seconds to
speak at the at the um at the actual
school board meeting which like you no
one can say anything in 60 seconds and
they make you wear a mask it's like this
whole ridiculous scene they had set up
we had to if you wanted to speak in the
meeting you had to wait outside wait in
a single file line outside of the the
room where the meeting was actually
taking place because they wouldn't let
any Spectators in the room and they
would call you in and you'd hear your
your name over the the intercom and
you'd come in and they'd set the timer
they give you 60 seconds at 60 seconds
they cut off the mic and say okay you
leave next person come in like the
single file thing it's a total absurdity
because they're just trying to stop
people right they know you can't you
can't really say anything in 60 seconds
so and that's that's the whole idea to
stop you from actually saying anything
Nathan Simpson says Tim you should try
the post-modern paper generator it's an
AI that shows how you don't need to know
anything to write this stuff agreed look
at a lot of the you know the the early
feminist YouTubers doing like gamergate
and listen to what they're saying and
it's like they're not saying anything it
is just buzzwords strung together to
make it sound like they're smart and
then they'll give you their point at the
end which is a simple statement it's
like now that I've said all these things
you can't understand this is why we have
to do X and they go oh it sounds smart
to me I guess and there are people just
want to fit in and be a part of it yep
they don't want to be weirdos if they
think it's popular they will uh get on
board
spartymat says I live in Oxford Mi and
teach School nearby please everyone tell
your kids you love them especially the
hurting and broken young men who
desperately need to know that someone
anyone cares about them yes
ipac says Joseph Stalin said socialism
is a necessary step that's correct yeah
Eric Miller says Tim socialism is simple
the means of production are controlled
by the people then the government
control the people so then the
government control the means of
production now if you made it this far
how do you like West China
yeah
there will always be in these systems a
centralized Authority and control period
there's there's there's no way for it to
work in fact the system has a tendency
towards power coalescing that's that's
it these people who believe that there
will truly be utopian communism are
insane as if they think they think raw
materials are infinite they think
housing is infinite they think conflict
doesn't exist they think humans you know
what it's simple you ever see the movie
equilibrium
I don't think so it's the it's with uh
Christian Bale and it's a society where
everyone takes a drug every morning that
suppresses emotion hmm okay
that and then sure you know you might
have a perfectly working communist
Society more of a Brave New World sort
of thing or are those called ssris yeah
something like that you get situations
where like one there'll be human for
humans but one of them will solve the
problem so quick and you're like wow
that's great then the second time it
happens he does it again and you realize
okay if we put our faith in and power
behind this guy we're going to survive
as a group if we let no I'm not pointing
any one of you guys but like random
people stumble around and make mistakes
trying to lead us then we're gonna die
so like it's this natural tendency
towards centralization of authority and
Powers kind of intrinsic in what we are
as a species I think it's necessarily
healthy though I think it's the same
thing that drives humans to innovate
actually
uh we don't want to expend energy it's
risky so through evolutionary biology
through the gradual natural selection
the changes
uh Humanity favored those who conserved
energy to the greatest degree that meant
people who would have higher access to
food who are smarter who are stronger or
faster could run so that way we'd have
more energy to procreate and those who
had less energy couldn't and that means
when it comes to politics people are
like the least amount of work I have to
do is better for survival so if you want
to take care of it I'll just do whatever
you say you have a lot of people saying
as confusing complicated hard and I
don't want to be involved
and then they give up all their power
yep
Simon Eric Alexia says hey Tim did you
know that you were mentioned in the book
this is a Swedish Tiger written by Aaron
flam I think I heard that huh I don't
know to what degree they mentioned me or
whatever
Sweden's a creepy country I have no idea
what the book is yeah
Dragon Lady says I asked sir what is the
militia it is the whole people George
Mason Founding Father of the Bill of
Rights there you go man
Colin Sanders says SBG represent we run
this show now we're taking over the
Internet we're the New World Order SVG
worldwide P.S Matt is the best daily
wire host oh snap I hear that I hear
that we'll have to have you uh um have a
host off everybody and when we come to
uh when we come to daily wire HQ yeah I
don't know what I don't know what that
would consist of I know that me and uh
you know being Ben Shapiro have a
long-standing thing where we're supposed
to have a push-up competition so he
keeps he keeps dodging me but through
the high speed camera he's probably
training really intense he's gonna show
up one day and he's gonna rip his shirt
off he's gonna be like super ripped I'm
like a six-pack and he's gonna be like
you made a mistake Walsh
Christopher Fisher says the idea of cops
as neutral Arbiters is entirely
fictional police in the US have always
been enforcers period full stop scotus
repeatedly ruled that cops have no duty
to protect or prevent crime I understand
that I'm not saying that you know every
cop that comes out is a smiling officer
friendly I'm saying if two people are
screaming at each other and threatening
violence the cops come and say I don't
know or care who either of you are stop
it or else you'll be arrested like
somebody who can do that you know what I
mean
yeah I'm looking at look I'm waiting for
some peacekeepers
well I'm surprised they're not doing
political Compass tests when it comes to
What charges or what jail they're gonna
go to
um you've been arrested sir now how
would you describe yourself
um
you get pulled over for a DUI and the
cops like sir you appear to be very
drunk
um on the political spectrum of left
versus right where would you uh find
yourself left I think your blood alcohol
is uh you know 0.03 you're you're you're
good to go it's called the social credit
score it already happens in China and
it's coming here to the United that's
right yeah exciting
Red Dawn 1984 says don't trust the media
Gobles made a propaganda videos
depicting life in the ghetto adults
laughing and children playing in the
playgrounds I know why it's remarkable
Claire Lehman she responded saying I
found this hashtag about Howard Springs
full of hot babes enjoying the the
quarantine camp that Tim call Tim Cass
calls concentration camps and then I
think it was Jack Murphy who said I
couldn't help but notice that there's no
photos of any regular people it's all
like hot babes and smiling families
waving at the camera it's clearly a PR
campaign it just makes it creepier yeah
it's worse yeah yep hot babes sunbathing
smiling bikinis and g-strings on yeah
look at you know footage from North
Korea everyone's smiling and happy and
clapping for you know their their leader
yeah that's not staged right now
attempting selfies Australia is creepy
man jeez
Vero Frady says we are in an era of
English socialism where government
effectively runs business through
regulations
yeah to a great degree I would say I
would say Yes actually actually and
there's a lot of regulations yep
Dave Guerra says Japanese internment
camps are not that far in the past ask
past ask George takai and that was here
on American soil I'd be interested to
ask George about Australia oh yeah which
side is he going to fall on that one
he's going to be like no that one's okay
yeah the one I went through was bad but
this one this one's okay yeah
all right home B says I'm more or less
concerned if terrorists actually try and
start hitting this country with roadside
bombs on American highways or some other
off-book things I can conceive I mean
in terms of Civil War conflict we're
definitely not at any point like that
and I hope it never happens it's
ineffective we are not in that era we
gotta we gotta win hearts and Minds you
know we gotta we gotta convince people
we have to be persuasive and peaceful
the the reason antifa it gets away with
it to a certain degree is because a lot
of people are scared but they do lose
public support which has a backlash to
it that being said my friends go to
timcast.com become a member one of the
members only segment coming up about
around 11 or so p.m don't forget to
smash the like button you can follow us
at timcastirl you can follow me
everywhere follow me on Instagram at
timcast Matt you want to shout anything
out
uh well I would mention my children's
book I don't know if I mentioned that
yet but Johnny I'll give a book Johnny
the walrus.com you can get uh my
children's book I'm a a I'm a
best-selling children's author which is
what I will be referring to myself as
for the rest of my life that's what it
wants that's what this was all about
actually was just so that I could call
myself a best-selling children's author
and start every sentence with well as a
best-selling children's author I think
this uh but yeah johnnyswaldress.com
yeah right on what's your Twitter
uh at Matt Walsh blog all right well
thanks for coming on it was great having
you uh and if you want to find out what
I'm doing I'm doing a lot of really
exciting things on Luke uncensored.com
today I did a video about my future
plans how people could get involved if
you want to see that just check out Luke
uncensored.com thanks for having me you
can also follow me Ian crawson.net if
you want a little bit more of this happy
to see you have a nice day catch you
later and uh I you guys can follow me on
Twitter at sour patchless I always enjoy
Matt's talks but I really enjoy this
kind of more personal I always enjoy
these long-form conversations so thank
you definitely yeah good times and don't
forget in the chat Russ action right now
on YouTube there is the step on snack
and find out shirt which you can pick up
we're actually planning on having a new
shirt once per week so we're not going
to be nearly as shirt prolific as Lucas
and our shirts are usually not super
political like with statements like
Luke's are ours are more of like silly
like the gorilla or the Sheba or the
snake so we're gonna have more silly
shirts like that and you go to
timcast.com click store and it's all
available there and it helps support our
work of course and of course best what
is its best politicalshirts.com
thebestpoliticalshirts.com Luke's got
the more political statements and uh
definitely to help support his work as
well so we're really grateful to all of
your support we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys